Doch jetzt, jetzt gehts wieder.
Jetzt kann man's einstellen.
Buck, Buck bei 48 FPS...
Also Leute, F5.
Jetzt kann man's einstellen.
Das liegt an 48 FPS.
Das ging die ganze Zeit.
Jetzt buggt Twitch anscheinend gerade rum.
Jetzt kann man's einstellen.
Das liegt an 48 FPS.
Das ging die ganze Zeit.
Die ganze zeit jetzt backtwitch anscheinend gerade rum geil
Ok leute dann würde ich sagen legen wir mal los ich geh jetzt noch schnell auf
Ich mache aber das game schon mal an
Weil die intro musik ist schon wieder grandios von dem spiel
Ich habe echt und scheiß leute ich habe übelst angst vor dem game jetzt ernsthaft also ich und ich übertreibe jetzt nicht
Na das das game das das ist so mit reißen dass
Ich war fertig mit den nerven als ich das das erste mal gespielt habe ich war komplett durch
Und das jetzt noch mit zuschauer dabei das ist ein bisschen schäbt das fenster
Ich muss mal kurz das Fenster einstellen das backt ein bisschen
Wir haben es gleich
Aber das soundtrack ist wirklich grandios an dem soundtrack hat übelst angst
Die sonnenblume aus plans vs. zombies mitgeschrieben und ich waren das ernst
Könnt ihr mal gucken wer an den beiden soundtracks beteiligt war
4 zu 3 in 2k 18
Okay leute ich bin mal ganz kurz auf dem klo ich bin sofort wieder da
Ich bin mal kurz auf dem klo ich bin sofort wieder da
Könnte bitte einer von den mods schauen ob kategorie also sprich ob spielkategorie und sprache auf deutsch steht und sowas ob das alles passt
Lautstärke okay jungs und medels natürlich wir respektieren ja frauen
Okay oh man ich habe echt schiss vor den game auf gehts
So die vorschau gucken ob das alles passt also der anfang ist ein bisschen gemächlich
Da wird das ein bisschen als intro ich habe es ja schon mal gespielt der anfang ist ein bisschen gemächlich aber man muss aufpassen
Weil viele sachen die man so sieht nebenbei ergeben später sinn nicht dass man es unbedingt braucht um es zu checken ja die story an sich
Versteht man auch so es ist überhaupt kein ding und das ist wirklich eine super geschichte ich finde das ist das jetzt mal ohne zu übertreiben ja das ist das best
Geschriebenste spiel was ich in den letzten zehn lang gespielt habe auf gehts und es ist ein rpg makerspiel dementsprechend sieht es auch aus allerdings mit komplett von hand erstellter craft also von sprites
Echt gut
Zum glück ich habe gerade noch kurz überlegt habe ich es auf deutsch gestellt wahrscheinlich nicht aber zum glück
Ich bin mir übrigens noch was muss ich erzählen bevor wir anfangen weil das spiel hat relativ viel text also ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich alles vorlese
Ja also die hauptdialoge lese ich vor allerdings wenn ich jetzt mit irgend so random npc lava oder so keine ahnung ob ich den vorlese also da sind die zwei dr.
Rosalie wo bist du mit deinen gedanken nein entschuldige vielmals ich bin das ist schwierig für mich ich habe überhaupt keine let's play erfahrung großartig
Der cringe ist real alter entschuldige vielmals dass ich hellenhaft versucht habe den plötzlich auftauchenden eichhörnchen auszuweichen das der übelste schwätzer der typ du hast trotzdem überfahren
Verstell die stimme bliesen auch ich kann das nicht ich kann es nicht ich kann ich hier auf den übelst krassen let's play stelzer machen du hast es überfahren und bis gegen den baum geknallt
Ja nicht so schlimm der wagen gehört der agentur was du willst der chef wird uns umbringen
Wir sagen einfach ich hätte einen hunden welpen gerettet er mag doch kleine hunde oder mag er sieht man im zweiten teil fällt mir bei der fällt mir gerade auf
Es gibt übrigens schon einen zweiten teil von dem game nennt sich finding paradise er ist eher ein katzen typ ne er mag hunde erinnere ich mich noch dran warum muss immer alles so kompliziert sein
Na gut wir haben unseren lieblingsfeldknoll gerettet so krise abgewendet gut das kann sich alles so in den bericht schreiben lass uns die ausrüstung aus dem wagen holen und losgehen
Die steuerung ist äußerst simpel point and click ausrüstung ab das müssen wir lass uns losgehen ich überlege gerade ob ich das erste mal in deutsch gespielt habe
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr gucken wir uns mal das eichhörnchen nochmal an
Ausweichen das auto nicht zu schrott fahren das ein bisschen viel verlangt übrigens fun fact im zweiten teil fährt sie auto am anfang
Hey warte mal was ist mit dem auto ich wollte nur sichergehen dass du es nicht vergisst wie du immer an mich denkst vor allem ne range von diesem türschließer
Gg der spoiler es gibt im zweit es gibt generell ein paar referenzen auf den ersten teil im zweiten wobei der zweite teil ist es es ist nicht wirklich ein zweiter teil ne also es ist komplett neu halt die die zwei ärzte sind die gleichen
Wer hatte einen felsbrocken hingelegt vielleicht ist das ihr sicherheitssystem
Oh Gott die übersetzung zu gucken nochmal unsere zeit ist zu kostbar für solche blödsinn versuchen wir ihn auf den weg zu rollen
Und wir machen einfach feierabend und geben diesem ding nicht schuld
Das hast du doch auch gesehen was war das kein felsbrocken so viel steht fest
Naja wir müssen sowieso weiter
Wir können später nochmal darüber nachdenken
Ja genau Punkt Punkt Punkt
Das hat er echt schön das haben sie echt schön gemacht ich meine für das dass es ein RPG maker game ist der leuchtturm ja ich kann mich gerade erinnern
Oh Gott das wird schlimm
Das wird schlimm
Für das dass es ein RPG maker game ist haben sie sich wirklich verdammt viel mühe gegeben
Hör rein
Das merkt das nicht
Sie sind da
Okay ich muss jetzt ich muss jetzt girlstimme machen aber das kann ich nicht
Die ganzen krassen let's player können das die können für jeden charakter eine unterschiedliche stimme machen kann das nicht
So mit let's play normalerweise ihr wisst ja ich habe zwei let's plays geschafft über drei jahre oder so
Moin scary lackey
Kein schlechter ort um mit rente zu gehen was
Da geht noch was
Nachtschichten liebst du oder hast du sie
Du kennst die antworten verdammte nacht eule
Die werden wahrscheinlich wieder eine nacht durch machen was du weißt du ist mir klar
Und ich bezweifle dass sie kaffee haben sie haben kaffee
Halt die klappe alter lan
Und das wäre es rauschen mit unseren oren sanft umspielen herr typ erzählt ein blödsinn immer
Davon kriege ich nichts mit wenn du so viel laberst
So auf geht's rein
Vergiss nicht die ausrüstung
Da gebe ich ihm recht für das werden sie viel zu schlecht bezahlt
Dr warts und dr rosalie nehme ich an
Danke dass sie so kurzfristig herkommt
Kein problem ich bin selbst nicht so gut darin tote vorherzusagen was
Hab ich mich da grad verlesen
Sind sie die tochter des patienten
Oh nein ich bin nur die pflegerin
Die deutsche übersetzung ist soweit ich weiß von fans beigesteuert
Ich glaube das ist nichts offizielles
Das sind meine kinder sara und tommy
Ich habe nicht gerade ein acht stunden job deshalb erlaubt uns schon hier zu wohnen
Ich nehme an dieser johnny ist unser man
Johnnie
Hören sie wenn wir es hier mit einem kind zu tun haben dann sind wir nicht die richtigen für sie
Nein nein er möchte nur lieber so genannt werden
Er ist oben sein arzt gerade bei ihm
Kommen sie bitte mit
Also dann schnappte den koffer los geht's
Wenn mein rücken eine sage schlapp macht verklage ich dich auf schaden so dass
Anzeige ist raus
Ich erinnere mich noch dunkel dass es nicht viel sinn macht hier am anfang
Um zu laufen zu gucken
Da ist noch nicht viel
Ok ab nach oben bevor ich dieses ding noch fallen lassen
Bis jetzt hat man noch keine ahnung
Was die beiden hier eigentlich machen ich hoffe
Ich bin mir nämlich nicht mehr sicher wie gut das das käme erklärt nach oben jo
Aber nachdem es der erste teil ist glaube ich war das gut ich habe es komplett
Gecheckt ok sie sind weg
Wer zuerst da erst darf die melodie spielen
Der soundtrack ist so toll
Dem
Ok jetzt ist absicht dass das sound ein bisschen leiser ist weil es von unten
Kommt für ihr alter sind diese kinder ziemlich gut
Du bist die jenige die ständig erzählt dass wir keine zeit haben
Go go go
Wobei ich rein zufällig derjenige bin der das gewicht eines
Kleinen mehr treten durch die gegend schleppen darf
Ja ja auf geht's
Ich erinnere mich wieder an das game
Als hat mich jules fertig gemacht
Das ist johnny und das ist der doktor
So übrigens auch in feining paradise vorkommen
Wollen sie aufbauen erst mal umsehen
Wollen wir absetzen oder wollen wir uns umsehen
Wollen wir direkt loslegen oder wollen wir erstmal ein bisschen im haus rumgucken
Ich glaube da gab es nicht viel ich setze erst erst mal um
Ich will nämlich noch mal gucken was hier drinnen war
Nix ok dann legen wir gleich los
Erst mal noch mal mit doktor reden
Er ist nicht mehr ansprechbar aber wie es aussieht tut er sein bestes um bei uns zu bleiben
So ghost qq
Schwer zu sagen wie viel zeit ihnen bleibt aber ich würde mich beeilen
Maschine absetzen
Doch man kriegt am anfang erklärt was die beiden eigentlich machen und vorhaben
Ich muss mal kurz schnell checken ob das sound
Die lautstärke so passt
Aber ich denke
Ja
Die lautstärke ist gut oder
Keine sorge wir sind die fachleute
Doch ist angenehm
Mist
Strom aus
Reine routine ich teste ob ihr aufpasst
Wie macht er sich
Nicht so gut wenn sie mich fragen er hat noch ein oder zwei tage
Das ist reichlich zeit
Ja genau jetzt kriegt man es ein bisschen erklärt sie beide können ihm also jeden wunsch erfüllen ja
Wir können es zumindest versuchen
Bis jetzt haben wir es immer geschafft denn wir sind einfach der wahnsinn
Er findet sich halt einfach geil
Also wie lautet der wunsch
Der mond
Er möchte zum mond fliegen
Und deswegen heißt das spiel to the moon wer hätte das gedacht
Die alten knacker werden auch immer abgetreten was
Also ist das möglich
Kommt drauf an
Das heißt ja
Warum erzählen sie uns nicht ein wenig über unsere kunden hier
Tja ich weiß eigentlich nicht sehr viel
Johnny ist ein seltsamer man in den zwei jahren die ich hier gearbeitet habe hat kaum gesprochen
Er hat sein leben lang als handwerker gearbeitet und seine frau ist vor zwei jahren gestorben
Mehr weiß ich nicht
Immer noch mal ich hätte mehr erfahren wenn ich seine verdammte was wenn ich sein verdammter zeitungsjunge wäre
Mach einfach deine arbeit
Und ja ich denke wenn sie sich im haus umsehen können sie noch einiges über ihn erfahren
Johnny hätte sicher nichts dagegen er hat sie beide ja schließlich beauftragt
Gut dann machen wir das
Also wer von uns beiden spielt direktiv
Ich glaube das letzte mal bin ich mit dr watts
Los gelaufen jetzt jetzt nenne ich noch dr rosen
Wie gesagt am anfang ist es ein bisschen gemächlich
Aber man muss sich ein paar sachen mehr
Danke für das angebot aber ich bin voll damit ausgelastet
Einen backenabdruck auf dem stuhl zu hinterlassen
Das könnte ich auch
Gut weiter machen
Tom und sara können sie herum führen
Sie sind wahrscheinlich unten am klavier
Leute ich muss schon wieder aufs klo
Warten sie kommen sie doch einmal kurz her
Ich habe hier etwas für sie
Hier nehmen sie das
Kabelloser kontroll monitor
Damit wissen sie jederzeit wie es johnny geht
Danke ich wollte sie gerade danach fragen
Ach genau sieht man das hier oben
Nicht dass es wirklich für das game relevant wäre
Speichern war
Hast du die drehen trüsen ab da
Am ausgang dann noch ist ja nichts passiert
Twitch versorgen das stimmt
So jetzt wenn ich gerade musik läuft ich muss noch mal kurz aufs klo
So
So wieder am start
Leute ich habe eine frage an euch
Und zwar
Soll ich noch eine ankündigung posten für den stream
Also sprich twitter oder vielleicht auf auf diese youtube community geschichte
Oder wollt ihr lieber im kleinen kreis bleiben
Quasi die leute die twitter die twitch folgen und hier über twitch reinkommen
Was ist was ist euch lieber
So bleiben oder noch ein paar leute dazu
Gehen wir mal zu sara und tommy
Was wollen sie für mich das haus
Das war eine kleine runde dem stimmen
Ich verdiene überhaupt nichts hier dran
Gar nichts
Führt mich das haus
Sarah und Tommy richtig
Eure mutter meint ihr könnt mich einmal durchs haus führen
Ok vielleicht machen wir das
Ok es sind alle für im kleinen kreis da lassen wir das am post keine ankündigung vielleicht später auf twitter mal gucken
Ich glaube wir brauchen einfach ein bisschen überzeugen das ist alles
Was meinst du tommy ich weiß die kinder ging mir voll auf den sack beim ersten mal durchspielen
Was möchtet ihr denn wir wollen eine trillion dollar easy clap
Und die zuckerstange die mama vor uns versteckt
Ja oder die
Watt
Das ist eine riesengroße zuckerstange oben in dem regalfach an das wir nicht rankommen
Sie liegt in der küche mama hat sie dort vor uns versteckt
Bis wir unsere ausaufgaben gemacht haben
Holen sie sie für uns und wir machen mit ihnen eine tour durchs haus
Wie sieht es aus
Also ich bin ja ganz ehrlich für lasst den mist und kommt mit
Guck mal ob das funktioniert
Wirklich zehn stück das ist easy funktioniert
Oder zwölf nicht mehr als fünf die haben sehr viele kalorien
Das wird mich jetzt weniger interessieren
Immer noch besser als eine auf geht's
Ja dann fühlt mich mal um
Ok wo fangen wir an
Dieser seltsame raum im keller
Ich mag den seltsamen raum nicht
Was meint ihr mit seltsamen raum
Sie werden schon sehen
Er ist gruselig
Wir brauchen aber die schlüssel
Der alte man hat sie in einem buch im arbeitszimmer versteckt
Ok wo ist das arbeitszimmer
Das ist das bad
Das haben wir hier nichts nichts
Im keller können wir nicht
Moment
Hatte nicht gerade gesagt ich soll ins arbeitszimmer und die schlüssel holen
Das ist der keller hier spielen wir immer verstecken
Ok wir brauchen den schlüssel
Ich habe mich gerade spontan dazu entschlossen ich lese nicht jedes dialog
Fenster vor
Wir können hier unten nichts machen wir müssen jetzt erstmal schlüssel holen
Die tür ist abgeschlossen
Ist das hier das richtige zimmer
Ok wir müssen jetzt immer das mit dem schlüssel besorgen
Wo geht es hier lang
Ich kann mich dann immer so richtig dran erinnern
Das ist der bücherraum der schlüssel für den seltsamen raum ist im dicksten punkt des oberen regals
Na wie praktisch dass der raum genau neben dran ist
Nein
Im dicksten buch das ist doch das dickste buch
Zimmerschlüssel jawoll
Weiter geht's
Jetzt gehen wir in den gruseligen raum im keller
Wo geht es in dem game also ja point and click adventure ist das neu
Das game ist von 2015 also es geht darum dass johnny der oben im bett liegt und ungefähr nur noch
Eins zwei tage zu leben hat einen wunsch hat er möchte auf den mond
Und
Die beiden hier also aktuell sieht man hier nur dr. rosaline der andere sitzt oben sind von einer firma die
Eine maschine besitzen mit dem man quasi johnnys gehirn umprogrammieren kann dass er denkt er war auf dem mond
Und sich so seinen letzten wunsch erfüllen kann obwohl es in echt nicht passiert ist allerdings müssen sie dazu raus kriegen
Was in johnnys vergangenheit so passiert ist um das ganze neu programmieren zu können
Die tür wurde aufgeschlossen
Das ist ja wie in einer höhe
Wir nehmen das moment
Ein haser aus papier gefaltet die sind wichtig nachher da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern
Die hasen kommen doch öfters vor
Haben sie es gesehen
Was wisst ihr zwar über die ganzen papierhasen
Nix
Der alte man wollte nicht dass jemand reingeht also haben wir es ihm nie gesagt
Es gibt sogar noch mehr davon
Wo
Im verlassenen leuchtturm der ist direkt an der klippe
Wollen wir hingehen ich habe die schlüssel
Dahin sollte ich natürlich auch nicht gehen oder
Lull
Erinnert mich daran euch zwei niemals in leis wohnung mitzunehmen
Also wollen wir zum leuchtturm
Ganz schön kalt draußen aber
Zum leuchtturm gehen
Oder hier bleiben auf die maschine warten leute was wollen wir machen
Gehen oder warten
Chat interaktion in 2k 18 null
Seit wann läuft das stream
Halbe stunde
Warten zum leuchtturm ja warte
Campen
Das ist mod
Warten wir
Wenn johnny für die hasen verantwortlich ist dann werde ich in seiner erinnerung vermutlich sowieso davon erfahren
Wpd ich habe gerade gefragt im chat ob die leute lieber
Kleine runde haben wollen oder mit ankündigung und es waren alle für kleine runde
Also ab nach oben mal sehen ob nein mit dem konfigurieren der maschine fertig ist
Für river
Was ist denn das für ein lied es hat nur zwei noten die sie ständig wiederholen
Für river von johnny
Du hast noch nicht viel du hast wirklich nicht viel verpasst
Wir haben noch gar nicht richtig angefangen
Und auch so wirklich erklärt was die zwei hier machen wurde auch noch nicht komplett abschließen
Du hast noch gar nichts verpasst eigentlich
Sag mal warum kommst du nicht noch ein bisschen später
Ist nicht so als ob der kunde wegsterben könnte oder so
Ich muss noch was erledigen
Ich muss auch was erledigen nehme ich unseren job
Jetzt komm von deinem hohen ross ich bin einmal zu spät und siehst dich gleich daran hoch
Sag mir wenigstens dass wir startklar sind natürlich sind wir das ich verstehe mein handwerk
Geiler sich findet
Der helm ist auf der kaunsch hopp hopp
Ach hier ist eine kautsch wo ist hier eine kautsch
Guck mal was die angehörigen sagen wobei die pflegerin
Übrigens entschuldigen sie meine neugier
Wie funktioniert das schreiben sie ihm einfach das ist gut jetzt
Ok das ist das ist gut zur erklärung dass man eigentlich versteht was hier passiert
Wie funktioniert das schreiben sie ihm einfach ein neues leben so wie man einen roman schreibt erklären
Nein man kann neue erinnerungen nicht einfach aus dem licht erschaffen
Und wie macht man das nicht wir das meiste erledigt die maschine
Natürlich wir werden nicht gut genug bezahlt um uns selbst die hände schmutzig zu machen
Kurz gefasst unser job ist es so tief wie möglich in seine frühsten erinnerungen vorzudrängen
Dort angekommen werden wir dann sein registriertes verlangen nach einem flug zum mond
Auf die rekonstruktion seiner umgebung und seines seines selbst in diesem früheren zustand übertragen
Und mit der hilfe eines wikis allgemeiner und persönlicher daten simuliert die maschine dann eine wiederholung
Nur wird ihn diesmal die motivation aus seinem registrierten verlangen sein ganzes leben lang begleiten
Also hängt alles davon ab dass er sich seinen wunsch selbst erfüllt einfach weil er das verlangen danach hat
Wie soll das gehen wir streben doch alle nach irgendwas im leben aber kaum jemand erreicht sein ziel
Nun in der realen welt sind wünsche und ambitionen im ständigen fluss die entstehen und vergehen
Jetzt ist ja philosophie hier vorlesung oder wie die leidenschaft wird die menschen auf ihren weg
Aber dann kommt ihnen das erste feuer abhanden und sie werden träge
Oh ja das kenne ich ich wäre auch träge stellen sie sich vor diese erste brennende leidenschaft wäre immer
Bei ihnen ganzes leben lang ohne nachzulassen es mag nicht zu scheinen aber das hat eine gewaltige kraft
Wo wir davon sprechen keine kraft der welt wird einem toten mann helfen können ich fange also besser an oder natürlich
Okay auf geht's also für alle die neu dabei sind war ganz kurz zusammengefasst
Aber wir sehen es jetzt ja auch das ist johnny der hier im bett liegt und wir sind dr. rosalie und dr.
Nile was das jetzt wie heißt rosalie ewa ewa heißt sie genau und sie sind hier um johnny seinen letzten wunsch zu
Erfüllen allerdings nicht wirklich und das ist das was die gerade erklärt was auch gerade dieser dialog da erklären
Sollte sie haben eine maschine dabei die quasi die quasi johnny's hirn umprogrammieren kann dass er eben denkt
Er hat sich seinen letzten wunsch erfüllt ohne dass es in der echten welt passiert ist und jetzt geht es eigentlich richtig los
Bereit oder nicht wir starten durch
Das spiel war so traurig ich habe echt jetzt gleich übels rumheulen muss im stream
Das sollte die letzte erreichbare erinnerung sein hier oben sieht man übrigens wie weit wir in johnny's leben sind also aktuell sind wir noch
Ziemlich zu dem zeit kurz bevor er gestorben ist kurz kurz an das letzte woran ich erinnern kann er ist ja nur nicht gestorben sonst
Könnten das ganze hier nicht machen vergesst einfach was ich erzähle blödsinn das sollte die letzte erreichbare erinnerung sein
Die aktiviere die sprache für alle außer johnny schnappen wir in uns
Jetzt kriegt man sogar noch mal erklärt die position einer zeit leise lässt sich jederzeit mit dem auszeigen oben bildschirm anzeigen genau also sprich wie weit wir in den erinnerungen sind
Aktuell sind wir noch nicht so weit in der vergangenheit
Und das schön ist dass man hier eben schneller läuft als in echt als also in der echten welt hier in dem spiel dann
Wo ist denn johnny und man sieht ja auch in den erinnerungen sind halt ist halt nicht alles ausgebaut ja also sprich an die sachen wo er sich
Nicht mehr erinnern kann sieht man halt nichts mehr aber hauptsache wir können die lichter noch an und ausschalten
Wo steckt johnny hier geht es nicht mehr weiter johnny ist am leuchtturm garantiert ist johnny am leuchtturm
johnny john jetzt ist es john was für eine schöne überraschung wir haben hier seltenen besuch also für alle die
Jetzt dazu kommt das ist die erinnerung von johnny dementsprechend ist hier vieles nicht so wirklich wie in echt
Mein name ist dr. eva rosalin und das ist dr. von meddard nicht dr. von matterhorn dr. lorenzo von matterhorn dr. neil watz
Ist ihnen der name siegmund agency of life generation geläufig oh also sind sie bein von der agentur das trifft
Sich gut ich habe gerade überlegt sie anzurufen ja johnny das hast du auch lily bring uns etwas t lily nun um genau zu
Sein haben sie uns bereits angerufen wir sind hier um unseren vertrag aus der nahen zukunft zu
Erfüllen vorsicht wenn sie von der klippe stürzen müssen wir diese erinnerung neu laden er ist immer so feinfühlig ja
Zeig etwas respekt als sein letzter erreichbare erinnerung also brauchen wir seine hilfe schlimmsten fall
Einfach neu sie sind hier um mich zum mond zu bringen oder ja john
Mein leben ist eigentlich ganz gut verlaufen nicht gut genug wie es aussieht ist so feinfühlig doch der watz also
Können sie das wenn sie mich zum mond bringen wir nicht aber sie selbst können es vielleicht warum wollen sie
Eigentlich dort hin ich weiß es nicht und ohne zu spawnen leute man weiß es eine verdammt lange zeit in diesem
Spiel nicht warum johnny eigentlich zum mond will aber ich glaube ich habe noch nie so in einem game geheult
Bis zu dem zeitpunkt wo man rauskriegt warum johnny zum mond will das spiel ist wirklich super geschrieben so weiter
Ich weiß es nicht keine sorge sie können es uns ruhig sagen wir müssen es wissen damit wir ihnen helfen können
Wollen sie rum das geld es muss doch einen grund geben warum sie zum mond wollen tut mir leid aber ich weiß es wirklich nicht
Ich will es einfach ich weiß jetzt schon dass ich diesen auftrag hassen werde nun gut johnny ich erkläre ihnen
Was wir tun werden wir müssen in ihre kindheitserinnerungen gelangen die liegen weit zurück zu weit für einen einzelnen
Erinnerungssprung deshalb werden wir schrittweise durch ihre erinnerung in die vergangenheit reisen sie haben uns dafür
Nahe zukunft schon die erlaubnis gegeben das beruhigen zu wissen sobald wir einen direkten zugang zu ihren
Kindheitserinnerungen hergestellt haben kehren wir hierher zurück dann kommt der moment an dem sie uns helfen
Müssten ihre kindheitserinnerung ihre kindheit so zu beeinflussen dass sie später astronaut werden oder sich einen riesen katapult besorgen
Klar ist aber sie müssen mehr dafür tun als ich weiß es nicht zu sagen solange sie mich zum mond bringen werde ich tun was ich kann
Folgendes um in die vergangenheit zu springen brauchen wir ein momento ein gegenstand der für sie eine hohen erinnerungswert hat
Haben sie etwas für uns
Der chat noch ihr seht das ist das ist einer von diesen hasen das sollte gehen nun sollen wir
Ladies first
Also man muss echt mal für das dass das ein rpg maker spiel ist echt gut aus
Wir müssten zuerst das momento vorbereiten vorbereiten bereiten wir vor jetzt kommen die sinnlosen minigames die aber mega easy sind
Was kugel anklicken um elemente zu drehen ja easy clap
Hochgradig schweres schwieriges minigame
Die sprung kann aktiviert werden okay weiter geht's moment was ist mit meiner privatsphäre gute frage johnny die lsa liest nicht
Wir versuchen sie so wenig wie möglich zu verletzen
Sebaro sich auch so sebaro hat gerade geschrieben ich glaube wenn das game in der cry engine oder frostbite wäre wird es viel an seiner atmosphäre verlieren ja
Ich habe es ja schon ein paar mal gesagt es sind videos und live streams ich kann so 2d sprites
Kann ich viel mehr emotionen abnehmen als 3d models
Liegt wohl an mir aber 3d models kann ich kaum emotionen abnehmen auch so in heavy rain oder so das
War alles jetzt nicht sonderlich emotional
Okay aber meistens lässt es sich nicht ganz vermeiden
Die privatsphäre zu verletzen von johnny
So viele hasen
Das wäre nervig gesehen zu werden
Zufrieden
Wie lang ist das spiel 3 4 stunden
Mein gott was sollen bloß diese ganzen hasen
Ist echt schön zu dem game
Hat er mich gehört
Das ist unmöglich
Es ist wahrscheinlich nur ein teil seiner erinnerung
Dann bleibe ich bei meiner argumentation
Es geht mit johnny ab
Wie auch immer hör auf zu quatschen und finde ein momento das uns von hier weg bringt
Stimmt der haser hat farbe der rest nicht
So um jetzt in weiter zurück in die vergangenheit zu kommen muss man
Die erinnerung untersuchen das ist aber recht interaktiv meistens also meistens gibt es dann irgendwas
Wo halt die geschichte voran bringt nicht einfach nur irgendwas sinnlos anklicken
Ein alter gepflegter rucksack
Stammt ja aus der steinzeit das werden wir gleich heraus finden
Das kaiser neue kleider von hans christian anderson johnny steht auf den hatten auf das auf das harte zeug
Die
Was die zurzeitige auf erwartung ist nicht so deins oder doch doch ich gucke
Was macht denn johnny hier leere bilder
Lass es wenn wir eben unsere anwesenheit in jeder erinnerung neu erklären müssen drehe ich durch
Was habe ich hier übersehen
Gehen wir mal wieder runter es gibt bestimmt weiter
An den mit dem regenschirm geht es dann weiter okay
Die ur läuft einmal hört kein ticken
Okay ich muss mal ein bisschen mehr meine maus über alles mögliche drüber machen
Den habe den habe ich schon untersucht
Dann habe ich oben irgendwas vergessen anzuschauen
Die ur läuft einmal hört kein ticken
Oh ein glas
Ein glas eingelegte oliven
Das gibt es daran zu wasen das sind eingelegte oliven genau das
Die blumen unten
Frische wildblumen
Okay wir haben alles entdeckt
Dann reißen wir weiter in die vergangenheit von johnny
Grinch is real
Wtf war das
Genug davon ab jetzt übernehme ich das zerschmettern
Die minispieler haben mich genervt als das erste mal durchgespielt haben es weiß ich noch
Ich habe dann irgendwann einfach nur sinnlos rum geklickt
Ich mag regen lieber wenn er durch mich statt auf mich fällt
Mir macht das so oder so nichts aus
Scheint so als würden die erinnerung sprünge immer nur einen kleinen zeitraum
Überbrücken wir müssen ein passendes memento finden sonst brauchen wir noch ewigkeiten
Ach genieß doch einfach die landschaft
Geht sie irgendwo hin jetzt nicht weiter guck mal johnny hat dieses komische ding dabei
Das blüsch nabelt hier immer mehr hat kein blüsch nabelt hier ernsthaft dieses tier
Sollte nicht das recht haben zu existieren die welt ist nicht groß genug für zwei von
Eurer sorte
Was macht johnny hier in gedanken an river e wilds sagen wir einfach mal in gedanken
An river tja wer ist denn river noch wissen was nicht es ist fertig river
Wie du so kann ich auch was wie du so kann auch ich nun jeden tag auf sie aufpassen
Auf das blüschtier
Sie wird nicht mehr alleine sein
Was ist das denn ich werde vielleicht niemals verstehen warum aber ich habe deinen
Wunsch erfüllt ich bin sicher auch an er ist dir dankbar aber wenn ich fort bin
Wer wird dann über uns machen
All dieses game das macht mich fertig
Wer sind sie
Ich komme nur zufällig vorbei
War sie ihre frau
Ich bin froh dass sie nicht übersetzt haben
Ein außergewöhnlicher name
Das hätte nicht passieren müssen
Sie hätte es nicht tun müssen
Aber
Sie würden das nicht verstehen ich verstehe es ja selbst nicht mal
Was hat er denn da stehen
Ich muss jetzt noch mal gucken was das hier ist was hat er denn hier stehen
Ach das ist der krabstein oder ist das ist ihr krabstein jetzt erkenne ich das
Das ist der krabstein von river
Ich dachte schon du wärst von der kluppe gefallen
Was hast du getrieben den ausblick genossen was sonst
Fortschritte gemacht große fortschritte riesig die sauerier artig
Ist das die musik von dem game ja das game was hat übrigens den soundtrack den kann man sich kaufen wenn man den entwickler unterstützen will ist super soundtrack
Ziemlich einsam hier
Also sein leuchtturm was erwartest du
Wie auch immer wir sehen uns auf der anderen seite die barriere
Musst du diesmal selbst durchbrechen viel spaß
Eine kaputte leuchtturm lampe
Also wir sind noch nicht sonderlich weit in die vergangenheit gekommen
Die
Hat max schon gewartet ja darum geht es denn
Da drüben geht es hier
Was zeigt die mindestbewegung die diese mini games sind mir sowas von wurscht
Hat er schon gesagt warum er zum mond will nein hat er nicht und ich kann ja auch sagen das wird noch bestimmt ein zwei stunden dauern bis wir wissen warum
warum johnny wirklich zum mond will
Da seh baro hier wieder mit absoluten insider informationen am start
Gehen wir weiter in die vergangenheit
River lebt
Und johnny ist jünger
Also sind wir ganze stück in die vergangenheit weitergekommen john das kommt ganz gut hin
Und schon wieder jede menge hasen am start
Wenn deine operation bezahlt ist wird noch genug übrig sein also macht ihr keine sorgen
Notlüge
Ach ja ich erinnere mich kann wir man muss man muss genauer drauf achten wie wir verredet weil
Ich hatte am anfang als das letzte mal gespielt habe weiß ich noch habe ich erst mal nicht verstanden
Was das problem also was was riva für ein problem hat
Oder was mit riva los ist habe ich beim ersten mal durchspielen erst zum
Nicht wirklich kapiert das heißt ich kann euch nur mal so ein tipp gehen guckt mal wie wie riva reagiert und wie sie so redet
Dann wird es dann zwischenzeitlich klarer was was mit riva los ist
Man sieht schon riva ist sehr direkt notlüge
So nennt man das doch oder nicht nein ich bin sicher wir können einfach
Ich mag es nicht wenn du lügst
Ich habe nachgerechnet ich weiß wie es aussieht
Warum willst du mich gegen meinen willen überzeugen wir brauchen das geld für deine behandlung riva
Ich weiß dass anja dir viel bedeutet aber das hier das geht zu weit ist anja dieses blühstier
Ich meine sie sie ist nicht einmal
Weißt du was mich glücklich macht johnny was denn
Weißt du es
Frauen logik
Und ich weiß es ich hoffe du kannst mir dabei helfen
Riva wenn die papiere für meine behandlung ankommen werde ich sie nicht unterzeichnen
Was du mit unserem geld machst kannst du selbst entscheiden
Ja wer spoiler fliegt raus sage ich euch gleich
Aber wenn du meinen wunsch erfüllen möchtest dann verwende das geld um das haus fertig zu bauen und dann möchte ich dass du nach ihr siehst jeden tag den du dort lebst
Besuch sie sprich mit ihr tröste sie
Wie auch immer anja ist riva
Ich bin sehr glücklich dass du mir das geliebt hast
Besuch sie sprich mit ihr tröste sie wie auch immer anja ist ich will nicht dass sie allein bleibt
Und was ist mit dir
Glücklich
Ich werde glücklich sein
Johnny
Johnny jo
Ich habe das hier gemacht
Sag mir was es ist ein farbiger hase gut job
Sag mir einfach was es ist
Es ist ein hase wie die anderen auch die du gemacht hast und weiter
Naja er ist aus paviar und weiter der körper ist gelb und der rest ist blau gut weiter
River
Ich habe ein lied geschrieben es ist für dich
Okay
Nun möchtest du es hören ja
Du hättest nicht extra das piano hochbringen müssen nicht schlecht johnny nicht schlecht das ding die treppe hoch zu tragen
Ich kann nicht sehr gut hören wenn die tür offen ist es heißt für riva
Warum so klischeehaft das ist nur ein arbeitszettel
Das ist nur ein arbeitszettel
Wenn man sich jetzt den sound genau anhört
Wir merken dass erst eine andere version von dem lied als am anfang
Wer ist diese anja von der beide gesprochen haben
Wer ist diese Anja von der Beide gesprochen haben?
Und was wir auch gesehen haben ist, dass River irgendwie
sehr
direkt ist und keinen platt vor den Mund nimmt.
Wie ist diese Anja von der Beide gesprochen haben?
Wenn die so wichtig ist, hätten wir sie nicht in seinen späteren Erinnerungen sehen müssen.
Schätze, er hat sein Versprechen letztendlich doch nicht gehalten.
Also nach ihr zu gucken.
Es sei denn, es sei denn was?
Egal. Ist auch natürlich Frauenlogik. Ja, was ist? Was? Sag ich dir nicht.
Aber vorher dreimal fragen willst du wissen.
Hey, das ist doch dasselbe Lied, das die Kinder vorhin gespielt haben, oder?
Vermutlich hat das ihn beigebracht.
Ach, weißt du, das hier zieht nur mein Testosteronspiegel runter. Ich mach mich auf den Weg.
Ich habe schon meine Memo-Links. Komm mit oder willst du noch selber weiterschauen?
Na ja gut, wir können ja hier nirgendswo hin. Gehen wir mit.
Gehen wir einfach.
Wwpd also zur Story. Johnny hat die beiden beauftragt, ihm seinen letzten Wunsch zu erfüllen, kurz bevor er stirbt.
Hey, schau mal, was wir hier haben. Das unfertige Haus, wo wir vorhin drinnen waren.
Ich wette, sie haben die Klippen gesehen und gedacht, es wäre noch nicht gefährlich genug, solange keine Leute darauf wohnen.
Johnny? Wie ist das? Nick hat angerufen und mich hergebeten.
An Leute, die sich Johnny nicht mehr so hundertprozentig erinnert, die sind halt so grisselig. Und manche sind auch komplett grau.
Ich habe dir eingelegte Oliven mitgebracht, die magst du am liebsten, stimmt's? Da ist das Glas wieder.
Ich hab von Ulva gehört. Wird sie wieder gesund?
Ihre Krankheit wurde erst spät festgestellt, glücklicherweise ist sie behandelbar. Aber die Kosten für die Behandlung?
Wir können uns nicht leisten, das Haus fertig zu bauen, Isabelle. Wir können kaum die Behandlungskosten bezahlen.
Ich bin froh, dass man ihr helfen kann, aber du kannst dir nicht vorstellen, wie viel dieser Ort ihr bedeutet.
Es wird ihr das Herz brechen. Ich würde gern helfen, aber Ted und ich können es seit dem Finanzcrash selbst nur knapp über Wasser halten.
Was wirst du tun?
Ich werde ihr sagen, dass wir es schaffen können. Dass wir uns beides leisten können. Aber River ist nicht blöd, die hat das schon durchschaut.
Ich möchte nicht, dass sie eine Dummheit begeht und sich nicht behandelt lässt. Du solltest sie nicht anlügen, Johnny. Du verstehst nicht, Isabelle.
Wenn sie die Wahrheit herausfände, bin ich mir nicht sicher, was sie wählen würde. Und? Wenn sie entscheidet, dass ihr dieser Ort mehr bedeutet als ihr eigenes Leben, dann soll das eben so sein.
Na ja. Da muss ich sagen, da kann ich Isabelle nicht zustimmen. Was hast du von einem schönen Haus, wenn du selbst stirbst und das Haus, da hast du doch nichts von.
Es geht darum, was sie wirklich will. Ihr Neurotypischen meint immer, ihr wüsstet, was das Beste für andere ist. Das mag ich nicht.
Und ich hasse es, wenn du mich so nennst. Itzy. Itzy Clap. Glaubst du denn, es geht nur um sie?
Was ist mit mir, Isabelle? Nach all den Jahren darf ich da nicht auch mal an mich denken. Ich kann Johnny verstehen. Johnny will nicht, dass seine Frau stirbt. Hallo?
Also wenn ich die Auswahl hätte, baue ich mein Haus fertig oder sorge ich dafür, dass meine Frau nicht stirbt, würde ich sagen, ich würde mich dafür entscheiden, dass meine Frau nicht stirbt.
Ich möchte nicht allein sein, Isabelle. Ich werde sie nicht sterben lassen. Das ist anmaßend. Ja Johnny, gebe ich dir voll recht. Was geht dir das an?
Wo willst du hin? Ich werde ihr etwas von der Klippe mitbringen. Als wird sie ein wenig trösten. Was du vorhast, wird davon nicht besser.
Nick wollte, dass ich dir das hier gebe. Er sagt, das Lied heißt Everything's Alright.
Ich glaube, das ist das Lied, was von der Sonnenblume aus Plants vs. Zombies gesungen wird. Ja. Ist ernsthaft. Gar nichts ist in Ordnung.
Johnny sagt quasi so innerlich gerade, piss dich, Alde.
Mit dem Gurkenglas geht es weiter. Jetzt müssen wir erstmal hier untersuchen, was es hier noch so gibt. Können wir in das Haus rein?
Nein, nicht wirklich. Ihr seht jetzt nichts. Es gibt ja nichts mehr drin, sondern ich will euch nichts fertig. Wahrscheinlich sollen wir lieber Johnny hinterher.
Stells Auto. Übrigens, wenn euch der Soundtrack gefällt, könnt ihr ja mal gucken, den gibt es einzeln zu kaufen. Und ihr unterstützt natürlich auch den Entwickler.
Max spielt To the Moon. Fils Batman. Noch fehlt es nicht Batman. Eigentlich fehlt das Spiel nie Batman, sondern eher Cryman.
Ach, ich kann da gar nicht hoch hinlaufen. Oh Leute, ich muss schon wieder aufs Klo.
What the fuck? Das gibt es doch nicht.
So, wieder da. Tender Formen wäre eine Möglichkeit. Ich kann auch einfach auf mein 3000 Euro Highend Klo gehen, so oft ich will. Easy clap.
Lösen wir wieder ein super anspruchsvolles, nerviges Minigame. Moment, zu aktivieren. Weil ich schon nicht oft genug auf dem Klo war, trinke ich jetzt erstmal was.
Ups, da wollte ich jetzt gar nicht hinklicken. Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
200 IQ Plays.
Ein Highend Klo, so richtig mit Stange zum festhalten und absenken. Klar, kennst du das doch? Hast du das auch gesehen?
Ihr habt es doch letztens gezeigt im Stream. Eingelegte Oliven erhalten. Moment, zu aktivieren. Jawoll.
Jetzt sind wir ein bisschen weiter in der Vergangenheit.
Also, zieh dir die Sache wirklich durch.
Das war nicht ganz einfach, wir mussten Ratenzahlungen vereinbaren. Aber jetzt, wo die Finanzierung steht, wird es schon klappen.
Und dann noch an diesem schönen Fleckchen Erde.
Aber das ist es nicht allein. Okay, ich gebe zu, das war nicht dem Game angemessen.
Das Spiel ist so sad. Ja, warte mal ab, das wird noch viel schlimmer. Aber du scheinst es ja zu kennen.
Ich bin gleich wieder da, ich brauche etwas frische Luft. Ich komme mit.
Ja, mein Freund, ist schon wieder ganz schön lange her. Wohl war, wer hätte gedacht, dass die paar Kilometer mal zu einer solchen Hürde werden würden.
Diese River, immer noch so still, was? Ach, sie ist eigentlich ganz gesprächig daheim. Und wenn sie mit Isabelle zusammen ist. Ich denke, sie ist einfach nicht gewohnt, dass du dabei bist.
Null, jetzt bin ich der böse Junge, was? Hey, also hast du River jetzt diese eine Sache erzählt von früher?
Ja. Wie hat sie es aufgenommen? Insgesamt ganz gut. Aber eine Sache gibt es, die mir noch zu schaffen macht.
Seit diesem Vorfall basteln sich andauernd diese seltsamen Hasen aus Papier. Origami Hasen? Ja, viele, jede Menge.
Ich habe auch früher mal Origamitiere gemacht für meine Tochter, als sie noch klein war. Was ist daran so schlimm? Ich glaube nicht, dass man das vergleichen kann. Nick.
Sie macht nichts anderes mehr, als diese Hasen zu basteln, Tage ein, Tage aus.
Unser Haus ist inzwischen voll mit den Dingern, bis oben hin. Sagt dir Isabelle nicht, dass so etwas bei Menschen wie River nichts ungewöhnliches ist?
Bei Menschen wie River. Schon, aber diesmal habe ich ein ungutes Gefühl.
Wenn ich sie darauf anspreche, antwortet sie mir nie. Stattdessen bekommt sie diesen abweisenden Blick, fast als würde sie irgendwas von mir wollen.
Und das seltsame ist, ich habe das Gefühl, dass da wirklich etwas ist, das ich ihr schuldig bin. Hast du mal Isabelle gefragt?
Ja, sie sagt, dass sie mit ihr gesprochen hat, aber auch nichts aus ihr rausgehen konnte.
Tja, ich bin sicher nicht der Fachmann hier, aber ich kann dir eins sagen. Ich kenne dich seit der Mittelstufe. Du hattest schon immer den Hang hier, um alles einen Kopf zu machen.
Du bildest dir da wahrscheinlich etwas ein, mach dir nicht so viele Gedanken.
Wenn jemand so ein Rat gibt, liegt meistens tatsächlich was im Haken. Aber gut, ich habe Zweifel, keine Gewissheit, wahrscheinlich hast du recht.
Wahrscheinlich, ich habe immer recht, Johnny.
Dr. Watts, Moment mal, selbst er hat keine, also Johnny hat keine Ahnung, was mit diesen Hasen los war.
Vergiss die dummen Hasen, wir haben ganz andere Probleme. Wir sind hier in einer abgegrenzten Erinnerung, es gibt keinerlei Momentos, keine Panik.
Wir können wahrscheinlich eins von ihm selbst bekommen.
What?
Sieh zu und lerne, ich muss nur kurz diesem Wirt einen Besuch abstatten.
Äh, dem da?
Hallo, was darf's sein?
Was geht? Haben Sie ein Glas eingelegte Oliven für mich?
Na, das ist ja das, was man immer, ne, also in der Kneipe, so.
Flo96 ist neu hier, sagt hallo. Oh, das ist ein neues Feature, hallo Flo96, das kenne ich noch gar nicht.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man, wenn man das erste Mal im Chat ist, jetzt irgendeine Nachricht schreiben kann.
Nice.
Ähm, haben Sie ein Glas eingelegte Oliven für mich?
Klar noch, zahlen Sie bar oder mit Karte. Check.
Hm, tut mir leid. Checks nehmen wir nicht. Tja, dann schreiben Sie es einfach auf meinen Deckel.
Moment, soll das heißen, Sie haben kein Geld?
Dich werde ich sowas von gesetten.
Hallo, was darf's sein?
Ähm, Little Samsung, wo spielt das Game also, wenn ich im Live-Kanal schaue?
Ähm, Little Samsung, wo spielt das Game also, wenn ich im Land kontinent?
Keine Ahnung.
Kein Schimmer.
Das Spiel hat überhaupt keine Rolle.
Ich würde mal sagen, irgendwo in Europa vielleicht, so Frankreich oder so, keine Ahnung.
Tagchen, haben Sie ein Glas eingelegte Oliven für mich?
Klar doch, zahlen Sie bar oder mit Karte. Schreiben Sie auf meinen Deckel. Heute mache ich richtig einen drauf.
Oho, geht klar, der Herr.
Hier sind Ihre eingelegten Oliven. Ich mache auch immer mit eingelegten Oliven einen drauf.
Danke, Kumpel. Dann wird heute jemand eine Menge Trinkgeld einstreichen.
Danke, der Herr. Ja, wenn der wüsste.
Du kannst ein Arsch sein, Neil.
Ach.
Möcht ich locker.
Alde.
Was mache ich jetzt mit eingelegten Oliven? Ich setze mich jetzt zu Johnny und rede mit ihm über eingelegte Oliven.
Na nun, sehen meine getrübten Augen der etwa ein Klieschen eingelegte Oliven?
So ist das. Sie müssen auch eine gute Olive zu schätzen.
Allerdings, ich habe mir gerade eben ein frisches Glas bestellt. Was für ein Zufall.
Darf ich? Natürlich, setzen Sie sich.
Wir kippen gemeinsam ein Kläschen eingelegte Oliven.
Oh ja, das klingt doch nach einem Plan.
Eva, Geschmackssimulation aussetzen. Jetzt.
Ich habe keine Lust.
Nein.
Dafür wirst du noch bezahlen.
Tja.
Und so sind wir zu unserem ersten Toaster gekommen.
Haha.
Alles in Ordnung?
Ja.
Mich nimmt nur das Geschmackserlebnis dieser eingelegten Oliven total gefangen.
Einfach wundervoll, nicht wahr?
Oh ja, man kann sich kaum vorstellen, dass irgendjemand diesen Dinger ekelerregend finden könnte.
Lassen Sie sich Zeit. Wir haben ja nur zwei volle Gläser.
Also habe ich gesagt. Hey, das ist... Also habe ich... Ist das Inscope oder was ist hier los?
Also habe ich gesagt. Hey, ist das nicht in Ordnung?
Und Sie haben mir Recht gegeben.
Johnny labert.
Und wissen Sie, was noch an unserer Gesellschaft nicht stimmt? Blabla, blabla, blabla, blabla, blabla, blabla.
Ich habe sogar dabei. Wieso? Darf ich mal sehen?
Hm, na gut.
Bitte sehr.
Das ist das Klavierstück.
Und anhalten. Endlich. Herr Amelwirbel, wie machen die Oliven die?
Halt die Klappe. Piss dich, Alde.
Momento gefunden.
Fang bloß nicht wieder an. Mach dir keine Sorgen.
Mach dir keine Sorgen. Siehst du? Alles nach Vorschrift.
Der Typ hat teilweise so den übertriebenen Cringe-Dialog.
Das lese ich jetzt nicht vor.
Ich versuche gerade mich in die Situation rein zu versetzen. Du versaust die Stimmung. Das war es wert.
Okay, machen wir wieder ein ganz tolles Minigame.
Übrigens, ich hatte, als ich das das erste Mal gespielt habe, hatte ich keinen Bock auf die Minigames. Da habe ich einfach immer wild rumgeklickt, bis sie gelöst waren.
Moment, hä?
What?
Ach so. Easy clap.
Hallo, ihr habt alles gelesen. Ja. Ganz bestimmt. Aktivieren.
Wir sind wieder am Leuchtturm. Und sie sind eine ganze Ecke jünger wieder.
Also wir sind ziemlich schnell gerade. Das Spiel ist ja auch nicht so ultralang. Das ist eher, ist halt einfach interaktive Geschichte als Game.
Heiliges Känguru.
Du bist kein Känguru. Du bist kein Känguru.
Heiliges Känguru. Du bist kein Australier. Ja und? Wir sind hier ungefähr 20 Milliarden Nanometer über Normalnull und stehen auf einem verdammten Lampenmast.
Spring einfach runter. Es ist ja nicht so, als könntest du dich hier verletzen.
Machst du Witze? Das ist wie Bungee Jumping ohne Seil. Alter, das ist so ein Schwätzer, der Typ.
Umbleiben geht nicht. Runterkommen auch nicht. Man, wie ich hasse es, wenn... Was? Reading Skills, lull. Umbleiben geht nicht. Runterkommen auch nicht. Man, wie ich es hasse, wenn das passiert.
Ich schwöre dir, wenn diese Ort... Eva, what the fuck?
Weichei.
Weichei. Das haben sie echt schön gemacht hier. Für ein RPG Maker Spiel.
River. Warum hat man sie wohl verlassen? Ich nehme an, sie wurde einfach nicht mehr gebraucht.
Nicht mehr gebraucht? Für Schiffe meine ich. Du weißt ja, wie das heutzutage ist, mit GPS und all dem Kram.
Come on, River. Dieser Ort bedeutet mir sehr viel und ich habe nachgedacht. Im Moment läuft doch alles recht gut für uns. Und wenn wir sparen ein paar Jahre lang, dann können wir hier oben ein Haus bauen.
Wir werden uns einschränken müssen, aber ich... Wir könnten sie vom Fenster aus sehen. Morgens, abends, wir wären immer in ihrer Nähe. Und wir könnten jederzeit hierher gehen. Sie wäre nie mal allein, John.
Ich könnte jeden Tag auf sie aufpassen. Ja, das werden wir.
Was werden wir? Ich gönne es ihr. Das meinst du nicht ernst? Du weißt, was passieren wird, oder?
Es ist, als würde man einen Zug bei meinem Kleisen zusehen. Da hat er recht. Das Ende ist nicht wichtiger, als irgendeiner der Momente, die zu ihm führen.
Was zählt, ist, dass die beiden hier und jetzt glücklich sind. Lass uns gehen.
Ich kann es an der Stelle nur noch mal sagen, wenn ich mir das hier so angucke, ich kann einfach, ich sag jetzt mal in Anführungsstrichen, billigen 2D-Sprites so viel mehr Gefühl abnehmen, ja und Emotionen abnehmen, als ich das in einem 3D-Model kann.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was da mein Problem ist in der Richtung, aber ist bei mir halt so. Moment mal. Sie haben den Leuchtturm Anja genannt, oder nicht?
Ich glaube schon. Dann hat diese River auf medizinische Versorgung verzichtet wegen einem Leuchtturm? Ist das nicht ein bisschen zu übertrieben?
Also ich habe in diesem Beruf schon Merkwürdigeres erlebt. Ja ich auch, aber ich gewöhne mich einfach nicht daran. Es kann dir ohnehin egal sein, sie ist schließlich nicht unsere Patientin.
Notiz Anja erhalten. Ok, Anja ist tatsächlich der Leuchtturm. Und wegen Anja wollte sich River nicht operieren lassen. Sie ist halt hart drauf. Aber das Schöne ist, es ergibt alles wunderbar Sinn in dem Game. Und wir werden auch gleich noch erfahren warum.
Ne, da müssen wir nicht hinterher. Hallo Fenris Blue. Die Musik ist auch wirklich sehr stimmungsvoll MaxPunch. Soundtrack ist echt gut. Eines der besten Game-Soundtracks, zu Game zu Musik ist wirklich super.
Ich glaube wir sollen hier runter. Kann man hier runter auf die Straße? Nee. Ah, ein Hasen. Hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen, hätte ich doch nicht zufällig drauf geklickt.
Neil bitte keine Cringe-Dialoge mehr. Vorbereiten.
Äh, Moment, Moment, äh, äh, äh, ich hab mich aufgepasst. Fuck, äh, äh, ich bin überfordert von, von Minigames.
Moment, wie, wie fun- Okay, okay, mal langsam, langsam. Ich bin verwirrt. Ah, ich bin nicht mehr verwirrt.
Ich bin nicht mehr verwirrt. 900 IQ Plays. Advanced Prane. Jetzt ist Johnny aber noch eine ganze Ecke, oder?
Ja, Johnny ist jetzt keine Ahnung. 40. River. Wo steckt River? Der Hase gibt es sonst nichts zum angucken.
Wo ist River? Wo ist Johnny? Das ist jetzt definitiv nicht ihr Haus. Das ist jetzt ein altes, anderes Haus. Ein alter Flügel.
Wiezu haben sie das Ding die Treppe raufbekommen? Keine Ahnung, aber ich wette das wäre ein Klacks für die TARDIS. Für was?
Das verstehe ich nicht. Damit steht fest, Pianos zu bewegen ist für jeden ein Albtraum. Und es würde wahrscheinlich eine komplette Episode lang dauern, das dort hinzubekommen.
Was ist TARDIS? Die würde ich mir sogar anschauen. Doctor Who. Hab ich nicht geguckt, deswegen check ich das wahrscheinlich nicht.
TARDIS kurz für Re-Dance. Das wahrscheinlich nicht. Okay, Doctor Who, keine Ahnung. Hab ich nie geguckt. Kann ich alles verstehen.
Damit kann man durch Raum und Zellen... Ach, sind das die Telefonzellen aus Doctor Who? Was sind die Telefonzellen? Ah, doch, das habe ich mir irgendwo gelesen.
Jede Menge Papierhasen wieder. John, Johnny, du bist so früh aus dem Haus gegangen um zum Friseur zu gehen. Der Frismeister.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass er hier mitspielt. Was machst du da?
Hasen. River ist immer sehr direkt. Hast du den Hasen gesehen, den ich für dich dagelassen habe? Ja.
Erzähl mir etwas über ihn. Okay, dieses Spiel macht River wohl öfters. Hä? Beschreib ihn. River will Johnny mit diesen Hasen irgendwas sagen.
So wie es für mich aussieht. Und Johnny checkt es nicht. Weil River fragt ihn jetzt schon zum zweiten Mal, jetzt im Abstand von ein paar Jahren, was er zu diesem Hasen sagt.
Und Johnny checkt es irgendwie nicht. Er war gelb. Und weiter? Ein bisschen pummelig.
Und? Naja, es ist eben ein Papierhase. Ich wüsste nicht, was ich sonst über ihn sagen soll.
Du benimmst dich merkwürdig, River. River benimmst dich schon die ganze Zeit merkwürdig. Ist etwas nicht in Ordnung?
River. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber ich habe gerade eine Art umgekehrtes Déjà vu.
Ich glaube, ich weiß, was mit ihr los ist. Aber selbst dafür ist das ziemlich ungewöhnlich.
Glaubst du, sie ist? Glaubst du das? Jetzt spuckt es aus, Jungs. Vielleicht, wer weiß.
Leider ist das Spiel schon so alt. Das heißt, einige von euch haben es wahrscheinlich schon gespielt.
Deswegen frage ich jetzt nicht, was meint ihr denn, was ist mit River los? Und nicht mit Karsten. Mit River.
Weil ich finde, wenn man aufgepasst hat, das merke ich jetzt immer am zweiten Mal spielen, kommt man eigentlich drauf, was mit River los ist.
Zumal das Isabelle früher vorhin auch noch quasi indirekt gesagt hat. Vielleicht, wer weiß.
Aber wie du schon sagtest, sie ist nicht unsere Patientin. Lass uns die Dinge zu Ende bringen, für die wir auch bezahlt werden.
Also was wir jetzt aktuell über River wissen, ist, sie ist relativ direkt. Sie ist nicht sonderlich einfühlsam und macht komische Dinge und versucht Johnny irgendwas mitzuteilen, was er nicht versteht, aber was für sie relativ klar ist. Und er sieht es einfach nicht.
Ah, okay, hier geht's weiter. Das ist jetzt der Tag, an dem sie damit anfängen. Also, hier, Hasen zu falten.
Guck mal, was Johnny dazu zu sagen hat. Nichts. Ein Eimer.
Viele lange orangefarbene Hasen drin. Ähm, habe ich irgendwo was vergessen anzuklicken?
Ich glaube, ich habe irgendwo was vergessen.
Hm. Hä? Nee, oben. Dann habe ich oben was vergessen.
Hier, das habe ich vergessen. Ein gelber Papierhase. Oh Gott, nicht schon wieder. Ah, das hätten wir am Anfang sehen sollen. Haben wir aber nicht. Das ist der dicke Papierhase, von dem sie unten gesprochen haben. Wir haben nicht richtig geguckt.
Wir sind point and click, Noobs. Nein, da habe ich nicht drauf geklickt.
Sagen die noch, was sie hat? Ja.
Man versteht was mit Riverloose. Man versteht in dem Game prinzipiell alles, was passiert am Ende. Woran man sieht, wie gut das Game geschrieben ist.
Okay, Nile. Neil. Oder wie, wenn man nicht ausspricht. Keine Cringe-Dialoge, bitte.
Nein, diesmal nicht. Okay, weiter.
Optimale Anzahl, drei. Lul, drei.
Max, fast richtig.
Sebaro, ich fürchte, das kommt noch. Aktivieren. Geh weiter in die Vergangenheit.
Also, dieses komische Schnabel-Tier hat irgendwas damit zu tun. Ich habe eine Donation gekriegt, habe ich gerade gehört im Hintergrund. Muss ich mal kurz gucken. Schau mal, danke für die Donation von CandymanGear. Du bist einfach der geilste Boy, der gibt 10,51 Euro. Danke.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter. Wo sind wir jetzt hier gelandet? Also, dieses komische Tier, das ist überall dabei.
Ich weiß ja die Hälfte von dem Game auch nicht mehr, bloß ein paar Schlüssel-Sachen noch. Und viele Sachen fallen mir jetzt auch zum ersten Mal so richtig auf.
Guck mal, dass wir nichts vergessen. Bei mir gibt es nichts. Einfach laufen und gut ist.
Sebaro, nicht spoilern. Aber das würdest du eh nicht machen. Muss ich dir nicht sagen. So, wo sind sie? Oder wo ist was?
Hier ist nichts. Wir sind genau falsch gelaufen. Wir müssen auf die andere Seite. Also, ich muss echt sagen, für ein RPG-Maker-Spiel ist hier wirklich sehr viel Liebe reingeflossen. Und Details.
Das ist die Stelle, an der früher das Haus stand, oder? Das Haus, das niemals hätte sein dürfen. Allerdings kommt das erst ein paar Jahre später.
Mal ehrlich, was finden die Leute an ungewöhnlichen hohen und gefährlichen Plätzen denn so faszinierend? Höhenangst. Stimmt, Neil hat Höhenangst. Stimmt, fällt mir wieder ein.
Neil hat Höhenangst. Das kommt in Finding Paradise noch öfters mal.
Mal nebenbei, was ist denn ein RPG-Maker? Das ist eine Spieleengine für 2D-Games.
Games. Also quasi sowas wie Unity, plus viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel einfacher und für 2D.
Wo geht's denn lang? Genau, hier stand das Haus früher. Was heißt früher? Äh, später wird das Haus hier mal stehen.
Was? Äh, wisst ihr was Leute, wir speichern mal. Das kann nicht schaden.
Der Rucksack. Und sie sind auch mal in der Ecke, Jogar.
Deswegen hast du mich damals angesprochen, Johnny? Ja. Wie sieht es jetzt aus? Schätze es gehört dazu.
Es gehört dazu. Nicht, dass es hier gleich jetzt FSK 18 wird. Hör mal, das ist lang her.
Es spielt eigentlich keine Rolle mehr. Aber Izzi, Isabelle meinte, ich sollte dir besser die Wahrheit sagen.
Ich hätte unser erstes Treffen nicht so vermasseln sollen.
Und so richtig mit Augenkontakt hat's River auch nicht. Das haben sie echt gut gemacht. Was ist das? Ein Hackysack.
Kannst du ihn bis zu Anja werfen? Anja ist wirklich der Leuchtturm. Keine Ahnung, soll ich das probieren? Würdest du? Klar.
Johnny will River beeindrucken. Natürlich will er. River, bist du verrückt? Geh weg.
Ich glaube, diese Erinnerung ist nicht so weit von der letzten entfernt. Was glaubst du, besteht da ein Zusammenhang?
Wahrscheinlich. Was macht was mit dem Rucksack los? Memento gefunden. Wieso hat sie sich die Haare abgeschnitten? Ich mag lange Haare.
Das Schöne ist, dass ich das Game vor drei Jahren gespielt habe. Ich weiß bis auf ein paar Sachen gar nichts mehr zu den wichtigen Sachen.
Minigame. Minigame Skills. Easy. Easy Clap. Schreckt Minigame. Aktivieren.
Isabelle. Die Störung wirkt sich bei jedem anders aus, John. Nur weil wir beide daran leihen, sind wir nicht dieselbe Person. Aber du musst uns doch irgendwie helfen können.
Anfangs war alles noch ganz in Ordnung. Aber jetzt ist sie nur noch distanzierter als vorher. Selbst wenn wir im selben Zimmer sind. Sie ist nie wirklich da. Das geht mir langsam an die Substanz.
Ja Johnny, das kann ich verstehen. Was ist schlimmer, als wenn du fragst, was stimmt nicht, wenn offensichtlich was nicht stimmt und da kriegt man als Antwort nichts.
Dann muss man ein bisschen weiterfragen. Jetzt erzähl doch mal, was ist denn los. Nein, nein ist nichts. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie ich das aushalten soll.
Nunja, ich kann nicht für sie sprechen, aber viele von uns wollen nicht alleine sein. Von uns. Eine ganz andere Frage ist aber, ob man das auch zeigen kann.
Es könnte der Grund sein, warum River Hasen bastelt. Dass sie sich damit schwer tut, heißt noch nicht, dass sie keine Gefühle hat. Sie ist schließlich immer noch da, oder?
Manchmal musst du dir einfach den Glauben bewahren, dass du ihr wichtig bist. Es ist nicht leicht, sich das zu sagen, jeden Tag aufs Neue. Ich weiß.
Sag mal, warum wirkst du eigentlich so normal, Isabelle? Easy ist eine grausame Abkürzung für Isabelle. Ich meine, habt ihr nicht die gleiche Sache?
Nunja, bei mir wurde es festgestellt, als ich noch sehr jung war. Es ist mühsam, aber nicht unmöglich, sich dann eine Maske sozialer Normen systematisch anzueignen. Jetzt kommen wir der Sache näher, was River eigentlich hat.
Weißt du, ich bin Nile River, ebenso wie ich sie bemitleide. Ich bin Schauspielerin geworden, weil ich mein Leben lang eine sein musste. Nicht nur auf der Bühne, sondern auch sonst immer.
Nein, Little Samsung, es geht immer nur rückwärts. Ich bin so gut darin geworden, weil ich keine andere Wahl hatte. Nur so kann ich normal sein.
Aber River hat das nie versucht. Sie blieb einer Außenseiterin und hat nie etwas dagegen getan. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie es nicht konnte oder nicht wollte, ob sie tapfer oder feige war.
Es gibt Tage, an denen ich die ganze Verstellerei einfach nicht mehr aushalten kann. Und dann merke ich, es ist zu spät. Die Isabelle, die die Leute kannten, ist nur eine Show. Und mein wahres Ich ist zu einer Fremden geworden.
Ich glaube, letztlich beneide ich River. Jetzt kommen wir der Sache wirklich langsam näher, was River hat. Ich glaube, es wird nie genau ausgesprochen, aber man kommt drauf.
Und wenn nicht, sage ich es euch nochmal. Ich habe noch nie eine Frau mit solchen Problemen getroffen. Dann hast du wohl bisher noch keine einzige Frau getroffen, Neil.
Das hier geht uns nichts an. Also ich denke, an der Stelle kann ich verraten, was River hat, weil man hat es eigentlich schon komplett erfahren.
Ja, Fenris Blue hat es erkannt. Also sie hat keine gespaltene Persönlichkeit. Sie ist Autist. Fenris Blue hat es erkannt. Sie hat Asperger. River.
Das wird, glaube ich, nie in dem Game wirklich genau so gesagt, aber es ist ziemlich offensichtlich.
Die Welt wäre ein schöner Ort, wenn sich die Leute Gesichter besser merken würden. Sprich Leute, die Erinnerungen egal sind, sind halt einfach grau.
Irgendwas Neues heute? Nein. Was liest du da? Das Kaisers neue Kleider. Deswegen hat das Johnny auch später in seiner Wohnung liegen gehabt.
Ich habe es geliebt, als ich klein war. Und tust du es noch? Natürlich. Nur aus anderen Gründen.
Als ich ein Kind war, stand ich total auf die Animorphs Serie. Ja gut, Johnny war ja auch ein normales Kind.
Weiß ich. Deine Mutter hat dir ein Animorphs Buch zu unserer Hochzeit geschenkt.
Ja, das war ein ganz schön merkwürdiges Geschenk. Ich war als Kind wohl ziemlich besessen von dieser Serie.
Was ich als Kind geil fand, war Super Teenage Mutant Ninja Hero Turtles. Beste Serie. Turtles, beste Serie.
Und wie Meister Splinter damals schon gesagt hat, manchmal ist Rückzug die bessere Verteidigung. Nee, oder irgendwie so.
Das fand ich geil damals. Warum hast du sie seitdem nicht wieder gelesen?
Ich habe die Bücher gesehen. Sie verstauben in der Garage.
Naja, ich bin herausgewachsen, schätze ich. Gut, Johnny ist jetzt auch ungefähr 35.
Da liest man vielleicht eher nicht mehr Animorphs. Die Animorphs Serie hier. Es sind eben Kinderbücher.
Was ist falsch daran Kinderbücher zu lesen? Johnny, was ist falsch an Kinderbüchern zu lesen?
Sie spenden Trost. Schon möglich. Ich werde mir wohl dieses hier kaufen.
Ich lieb mich und du liebst dich. Wir lieben uns ganz fürchterlich. Hey River, das hier ist gar nicht mal so schmalzig.
River? Gut, schon wieder weg. Social heulen, was ist das? Das wirst du gleich noch sehen.
Und was ist mit Davids? Der ist mein Lieblingscharakter. John, ähm, keine Ahnung. Worüber redet ihr? Animorphs. Kennen sie das?
Nein. Ja, natürlich kennen nie Animorphs, was sonst? Ich habe keine Ahnung was es ist, aber es hört sich an wie so etwas wie Turtles, was ich früher geguckt habe.
Wirklich? Mehr oder weniger. Oh, wissen sie in welches Tier sich David verwandelt? Was weiß ich in welches Tier sich David verwandelt?
In eine A-Meise. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo ist denn das S? Aber geht nicht, fuck. Das klickt nicht richtig. Keine Sorge, ich finde es schon noch heraus.
Was? Ah, in eine Cobra verwandelt er sich. Okay. Du hättest es doch einfach googeln können. Okay, das spielt nicht so lange in der Vergangenheit.
Cobra. In eine Cobra verwandelt er sich. Okay, das muss man als... Ja, ich weiß es. In eine Codra. Ha, richtig. Eine Codra. Beatport. Wir spielen To The Moon. Das geht hier ab.
Ich wünschte wirklich sie hätten noch die alten Cover statt diese Ödenumschläge. Ist wirklich cool. So, jetzt haben wir alle Momentos zusammen. Jetzt können wir eigentlich weitermachen.
Pschu. Zumindest wissen wir jetzt, dass River Autist ist. Autistin. Wir respektieren ja Frauen. Kann man nicht so rumdrehen, das Ganze? Ist ja doof.
Moment, man kann nicht so rumdrehen, ne? Oh Gott, ich bin schlecht. Schlecht in diesen komischen Puzzlen.
Ja, aber spielt ihr das ernsthaft? Sieht nicht aus wie ein typisches Max Game. Man sollte sich nicht von der Optik eines Games so sehr darauf festlegen, was das für ein Game ist.
To The Moon ist eines der besten... Wie nennt man das? Es ist ja kein Spiel in dem Sinn. Quasi Buch in Spielform, was ich je gespielt habe.
Aktivieren. Visual Novels, genau. Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Und vor allem eines der Spiele mit dem besten Soundtrack überhaupt. So, jetzt dürfte Johnny so ein paar in 20 sein, würde ich sagen.
Och, es gehen schon alle. Ich bin doch gerade erst da. Scheint dir beim Partys häufiger so zu passieren.
Ach komm, heb dir deine kindlichen Scherzen für Leute ohne Selbstbewusstsein auf.
Guck mal, da ist wieder das Olivenglas und das Buch. Ich sehe. Le Fromage. Was? Oh, es ist Französisch. Aber wo ist die Maus?
Neil, manchmal check ich deine Witze nicht. Du redest ja immer viel Blödsinn, aber das ist bisher das Highlight des Abends. Willst du nicht eher sagen, dass ich nur Käse rede?
Wo sind wir denn jetzt? Irgendwo im Wald? Warum stehen im Wald so viele Leute, mit denen ich nichts anfangen kann? Wo sind die denn überhaupt alle? Was machen die hier?
Ich gehe jetzt nicht weiter. Ah, Patrick, siehst du, jetzt habe ich den Witz auch kapiert. Ich brauche halt, ich bin ja schon 33, das braucht man nicht.
Auch kein Big Brain. Wir kommen echt gut voran in dem Game. Ich glaube, das letzte Mal habe ich länger gebraucht.
Ich habe auch alles angeguckt und so. Jetzt sind sie mal eine ganze Ecke jünger. Paarundzwanzig, ich würde mal sagen, kurz nach ihrer Hochzeit.
Okay, man kann nicht mit ihnen reden. John, fühlt es sich anders an? Ich meine jetzt, wo wir die Ringe tragen.
Nein, River ist da immer sehr direkt. Warum, fühlst du dich anders? Also eigentlich, ja, ich denke schon.
Wie fühlt es sich an? Es ist einfach anders. Wahrscheinlich nur die Verantwortung. Verantwortung? Hä?
Magst du den Namen Anja? Jetzt wissen wir, warum der Leuchtturm so heißt. Möchtest du sie Anja nennen?
Ich verstehe. Anja ist ein schöner Name für sie.
Nachdem wir jetzt wissen, dass River Autist ist, ergibt das auch viel mehr Sinn, warum sie manchmal so Sachen erzählt, die vielleicht jetzt erstmal ein bisschen merkwürdig klingen.
Hey, komm mal her.
Cebaro sagt, River ist so niedlich. Ja, finde ich auch.
Oh, das ist keine gute Idee. Ich werde stolpern und fallen. Keine Sorge, folge einfach meinen Schritten.
Ach ja. Huch, ouch, mein Hintern. Ich glaube, du müsstest mir auf den Fuß gedrehten. Äh, ups. Komm, versuchen wir es nochmal.
Jetzt ist ihre Hochzeit.
Das tue ich.
Und möchtest du diesen Mann, der nun vor dir steht, Johnny Wiles, zu deinem Ehemann nehmen? Versprichest du ihm zu lieben, zu ehren, in guten wie in schlechten Tagen, bis dass er tot euch heidet?
Ja. Kraft meines Amtes erkläre ich euch hiermit zu Mann und Frau. Meine Damen und Herren, vor ihnen stehen Mister und Mrs. Wiles.
Ah, die Hochzeit. Äh, ja, was dachtest du denn, was das wird? Ihr habt sich so mit Hochzeiten, das ist alles. Flüssigkeiten sammeln sich in meinen Augen.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass du so sentimental sein kannst, nein. Oh, sag dich Augen, äh, ich mein Mund. Und da sammeln sich nicht nur Flüssigkeiten, sondern auch Festes.
Das ist ein reizender Gedanke, nein. Das wollte ich schon immer mal wissen.
Komm, lass uns einen Weg hier rausfinden. All diese Glücksähligkeit ist selbst für mich zu viel, ne.
Nein, ich mag es einfach nicht, anderen dabei zuzuschauen, wie sie Fehler begehen.
Frau Doktor, wo bleibt denn ihr Augenblick, was, wo bleibt ihr, der Augenblick zählt?
So, können wir hier noch irgendwas einsammeln, ne.
Uns fehlt noch ein, ich hab jetzt irgendwas vergessen, uns fehlen noch zwei.
Ach, hier unten geht's weiter.
Aus Gurkenklaas.
Ha, ich sollte mal schauen, wie es meiner Tante geht.
Alles klar, Mama, sag ihr, dass ich mich freue, dass sie gekommen ist.
Mach ich.
Übrigens, mal ein Hinweis drauf, wenn, wenn das Mama von Johnny ist, ist das Mama von Johnny?
Dafür ist sie aber ganz schön verschwommen, oder?
Meinen seine Mutter erinnert man sich normalerweise?
Ich bin so stolz auf dich, Johnny.
Der Nick ist wieder am Start, Joey.
Ach, so hieß mein Großvater.
Ach, Moment, hat, hat, hat sie ihn grad Johnny oder Joey genannt?
Hm.
Er ist gestorben, bevor ich geboren wurde.
Mama nennt mich manchmal so als Spitznamen, ja, sie hat, sie hat Joey gesagt.
Oh, ah, scheiße, ich erinnere mich wieder, was mit Joey auf sich hat.
Ohje.
Nick, wie kommt es, dass du mir nie davon erzählt hast?
Weil ich besser finde, wenn du mich John nennst.
Johnny, nicht noch eine von diesen Großeltern Kindheit, Großeltern Kindheiten.
Wieso, was hast du dagegen?
Ich meine, über deinen Großvater erzählst du immer eine ganze Menge.
Was? Stimmt doch gar nicht.
Ganz wie du meinst.
Joey erhalten.
Tja, wer ist Joey?
Johnny Spitzname nach seinem Großvater.
Ah, ich erinnere mich, dass das nicht so einfach war.
So, hab ich jetzt irgendwo was vergessen?
Wo geht's denn weiter?
Äh, heute ist noch irgendetwas aufgefallen, wo es weitergeht?
Ah, hier unten können wir noch mal gucken.
Ich bin so stolz auf Joey.
Warum Joey?
Okay, was hab ich denn vergessen?
Und vor allem, wo ist dieses, das, das Momento, wo es weitergeht?
Hier kann man ja nichts anklicken.
Ach, hier unten geht's weiter.
Hm, was ist da los?
Da kann man nichts mal machen, River.
Ich bin sicher, es war keine Absicht.
Komm schon, wir kommen zu spät.
Warte mal, ist das ein Hase?
Ach ja, weil eben jemand gesagt hat im Chat, er hat das Gefühl, dass die Erinnerungen vorwärts und rückwärts gehen.
Also die Szenen, die gehen immer nur von vorne nach hinten, also von hinten nach vorne.
Allerdings in so einer Szene, je nachdem, wo man hingeht, können die Ereignisse schon in unterschiedlicher Reihenfolge sein.
Also das ist jetzt ja eindeutig vor ihrer Hochzeit, weil sie sind ja gerade auf dem Weg zur Hochzeit.
Warte mal, ist das ein Hase?
Was meinst du, ist das der Ursprung der ganzen Papierhasen?
Warum sollte sie sich an der Sache mit dem überfahrenden Tier dermaßen festbeißen?
Vor allem erst so viele Jahre danach.
Was fragst du mich? Du bist hier die Frau.
Davon werde ich erst überzeugt sein, wenn du dich traust, einen Banschiesprung ohne Seil zu machen.
Tote Hase, hat das irgendwas damit zu tun?
Da kommt jetzt das Minigame.
So, jetzt kommen wir immer mehr in die Jugend von Johnny.
Du weißt, dass es eine fantastische Hochzeit war, wenn das Momento ein überfahrendes Tier ist.
Vielleicht sah sie das als eine Art Metapher für die schreckliche Ehe.
Und ein Jahre später fingen sie an, Hasen zu falten, weil sie sich daran erinnerte, wie sehr das hier zum Himmel steigt.
Ja, Nile fantasiert ja nichts zusammen.
Oder, was weiß ich, irgendwas ähnlich wichtig Tourisches.
Cool. Cool Story, Bro.
Da ist der Hase, armes Ding.
Was ist das heute für ein Tag mit den ganzen überfahrenden Tieren? Schau mich nicht so an.
Es riecht nach Bauernhof hier. Und nach überfahrenden Tieren.
Lass uns den Geruchssimulator deaktivieren und schleumigst von dir verschwinden.
Jetzt geht es hier eigentlich rein.
Splatter.
Was? Ein krass animiertes Hors.
Da kann Billy Ohr einpacken.
Lass es sein. Was genau soll ich sein lassen? Das weißt du genau.
Ich soll es sein lassen, nicht auf diesem Pferd zu reiten.
Wie alt bist du? 5? 12, by the way.
Okay, ich werde auf keinen Fall auf diesem Pferd reiten.
Auf geht's. Hör auf, Zeit zu verschwenden, Nile.
Fuck, das ist nicht gut. Und mach was, steh nicht bloot rum.
Verdammt, das stand nicht in meiner Stellenbeschreibung.
Was sagt die Notiz zu Dr. Nile? Äh, Dr. Watts.
Wo sind wir jetzt hier gelandet? Auf dem Bauernhof.
Ist aber nichts. Und die Erinnerungen hören hier halt auch auf.
River und Johnny. Jetzt würde ich mal sagen, so, keine Ahnung, 20 Jahre oder so.
Soll ich auf das Pferd drauf und mit rein? Nee.
Moment, was ist hier denn? Geht's jetzt hier weiter oder nicht?
Äh, hallo? Hab ich irgendwas übersehen?
Ich glaube, ich hab irgendwas übersehen, oder?
Kann doch nicht sein, dass ich hier so lange rumlaufen muss, vor allem in diesem Schneckentempo.
Ja, und hier ist die Erinnerung fertig. Hä?
Geht's die Straße wieder? Ich muss doch auf das Pferd drauf, oder?
Also, ich kann mich da noch dunkel dran erinnern, oder muss die hier jetzt Pferd reiten?
Ach guck mal, da bewegt sich was da oben.
Äh, ein bisschen verbacktes Pferd.
Musst du hier nicht reiten? Doch, ich muss reiten, aber irgendwie check ich nicht, was ich genau machen muss, weil aufs Pferd klicken ging nicht.
Äh, hallo?
Ich muss reiten, ich weiß das, ich kann mich da noch dran erinnern, ich muss hier definitiv reiten.
Ist das verbackt? Ah, nee, ich muss einfach ein bisschen nach rechts laufen, oh mann.
Ob das wirklich eine gute Idee ist, die kommt schon klar, sie macht das nicht zum ersten Mal.
Aber sie ist bisher noch nie alleine geritten. Ich kann das, ich bin kein Kind.
Oh. River!
Ja, ich stand einfach an der falschen Seite.
Worauf warst du? Komm schon.
Ey, wart auf mich. Jetzt darf ich da wahrscheinlich drauf.
Steht praktischerweise noch ein Pferd für mich dabei.
Ich frag mich, ob ein Alt schon von dem Pferd runtergekommen ist.
Eva!
Was für ein Spast.
Ach, zum Maiskolben damit, tolle Übersetzung.
Oh, Pfeiltasten.
Was? Nähertaste zum Kalubieren, jetzt ziehen sie aber alle Register vom RPG Maker.
Bam, schreckt. Danke dir, ouch.
Wer muss ich jetzt hinterher reiten?
Einfach rumreiten, oder?
Nicht in den Busch reiten.
Ja, wir haben es geschafft.
Wo, wo ist das nächste Moment?
Das Pferd, äh, ich speichere mal.
Wo ist das nächste Momento?
Memento, oder wie immer das Ding heißt.
Wo geht es weiter?
Wo ist eigentlich Johnny?
Äh.
Hier, dieses Momento wird uns weiterhelfen, aber ich setze mich nicht nochmal auf dieses Pferd.
Besorgt die restliche Memory Links, habe ich doch.
Vorbereiten.
Habe ich jetzt irgendwas verpasst hier? Nee, ne?
Ich habe eigentlich alles. Ich habe alle Links.
Johnny ist auch hier noch am rumreiten.
Wir sind fertig.
Was zur Hölle spielst du das?
Weil es ein geiles Game ist.
Eines der am besten geschriebenen Storys der letzten paar Jahre in dem Spiel.
Oh nee, ich habe es wieder verkackt. Warte mal.
Hm.
Wisst ihr was, ich klicke jetzt einfach sinnlos rum.
Ich habe keinen Bock auf diese dummen Spielchen.
Äh.
Sag mal, habe ich jetzt alles hier drinnen gefunden?
Ist das Absicht, dass ich jetzt vom Pferd dieses Ding auslösen muss?
Wahrscheinlich. Aktivieren.
200 IQ.
900 IQ.
Sind wir im Krankenhaus, würde ich sagen.
Johnny, die Diagnose steht fest.
Dr. Lee.
Ja, wir sind uns einig, was die Ergebnisse angeht.
Leider, und dieses Schicksal teilen sie mit vielen Menschen, die von einer tiefgreifenden Entwicklungsstörung betroffen sind, kommt die Diagnose spät.
Hätten sie davon schon gewusst, als sie noch klein waren, hätte es ihnen vieles ersparen können.
River, haben sie irgendwelche Bücher darüber?
Dieses hier ist von Tony Adwood. Er ist eine Koryphäe auf diesem Gebiet. Gibt es den Typ wirklich?
Sie können es erstmal ausleihen, kostenlos.
Brennen sie uns nur nicht damit durch.
Danke, Doc.
Nun, sind sie beide ein Paar? Unverheiratet und ohne sonstige rechtliche Bindung.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Nun, ich könnte sie an einen spezialisierten Therapeuten überweisen, wenn sie das möchten.
Gibt es irgendwelche Schwierigkeiten in ihrer Beziehung?
Nein. Ja, für River ist das ganz klar. Johnny sieht das mit Sicherheit komplett anders.
Und wie sehen sie das?
Äh, nein, alles in Ordnung. Wie auch immer. Sie sollten das Buch ebenfalls lesen.
Der Sibaro.
Der Sibaro hat hier wieder den Wikipedia-Artikel rausgekramt.
Tony Adwood ist ein britischer klinischer Psychologe.
Er ist auf das Asperger-Syndrom spezialisiert und hat zahlreiche Bücher und andere Medien über dieses Thema veröffentlicht.
Das bekannteste und zahlreiche sprachenübersetzte Buch ist Asperger-Syndrom.
Der deutsche Titel lautet Das Asperger-Syndrom. Das erfolgreiche Praxishandbuch für Eltern und Therapeuten.
Also sprich, das hat der Doktor gerade River gegeben.
Und ich glaube, spätestens in diesem Moment ist klar, dass das Spiel uns sagen will, River ist autist.
Es wird ihnen helfen, den Zustand ihrer Partnerin zu verstehen.
WPD trollt wieder übelst rum.
Äh, lieber nicht.
Wieso nicht?
Also, Johnny, komm jetzt. Stell dich mal nicht so an.
Nun gut, das ist ihre Entscheidung.
Für die vorläufige Behandlung gibt es die sogenannte Hypotherapie. Die könnt ihr helfen.
Eine Ranch nördlich von hier bietet sie an. Ihr könntet das in die Wege leiten.
Ach, deswegen waren sie Pferde, Pferde, Rennen, Reiten, Freund.
Ich hab's dir doch gesagt.
Dr. Rosalie wusste schon die ganze Zeit.
Wollte bloß nicht spoilern.
Guck mal, jetzt kriegen wir auch erzählt, wer Tony, Tony, Tony Dinksbums Edward ist.
Der Autor einer Buchreihe über Rivers Störungen.
Nee, das kann man doch nicht aufmachen.
Entschuldigen Sie, könnten Sie bitte die Uhr leise stellen? Sie kann das Ticken nicht gut ertragen.
Ist nicht so schlimm, ich halt's schon aus.
Ein Problem, das mach ich gerne.
Falls es noch etwas gibt, was Sie beunruhigt, sagen Sie mir einfach Bescheid.
Ja, wenn Ärzte nur so nett wären, beziehungsweise Sprechstunden helfen.
Hier aktuell würden die eher sagen, piss dich, Alde, dann wart woanders.
Zumindest hab ich den Eindruck in vielen Praxen, dass das die überhaupt nicht mehr juckt.
Dr. Rosalie, das erklärt wohl die Uhren im Haus.
Könnt ihr euch noch an Anfang erinnern, da sind wir durch das Haus und alle Uhren haben nicht mehr getickt.
Guck mal, da ist wieder das Schnabeltier.
Was hat das mit dem Schnabeltieraufsicht?
Ein Plüschnabeltier.
Ich kann es nicht fassen, dass diese Schäuslichkeiten zur frühen Erinnerung auftaucht.
Da hat jemals ein Plüschtier wohl sehr sorgsam behandelt.
Und hatte was Tiere angeht einen ziemlich miserablen Geschmack.
Nicht mehr lange, sie werden dich gleich aufrufen.
Okay.
Jetzt wissen wir es offiziell.
Auch wenn wir es vorher schon geahnt haben und nicht es vom ersten Mal spielen noch im Hinterkopf hat.
River ist, hat Asperger.
Ist, hat Asperger.
Äh, wat?
Moment.
Hab ich, hab ich was vergessen?
Moment, ich hab.
Äh.
Wo hab ich vergessen was einzusammeln?
Hier.
Eine einfache gelb-braune Handtasche.
Okay.
Äh, so?
Bip, bip, bip, bip.
So?
Oh, big brain, big brain plays.
Big brain.
Aktivieren.
Wo sind wir denn hier gelandet jetzt?
Ist das irgendwie im Theater oder sowas?
Und jetzt ist Johnny ziemlich jung.
Die Pockers.
Passt.
Äh, nicht passt.
Psst, schau.
Ich weiß.
Ich kann auch nicht glauben, dass er für sie diesen Film bezahlt hat.
Nein du Idiot.
Schau wir sind gesprungen.
Johnny ist jetzt ziemlich jung.
Was ist Johnny?
14?
Der Bengel ist allein im Kino.
Was für ein Versager.
Du gehst ständig allein ins Kino.
Äh, das ist was anderes.
Niemand ist kompetent genug meinen Geschmack zu verstehen.
Aber das mal außen vor.
Wie kann sich jemand diesen Müll hier antun?
Und daraus folgt, dass der Film auf Hand an...
Was?
Oh, Reading, Reading Skills Max.
Und daraus folgt, dass der Film auf der Handlungsebene wie auch der Meta-Ebene ein Völliger Reinfall ist.
Natürlich.
Komm schon, gehen wir.
Was?
Ach ja, richtig.
Go, go, go.
Gehen wir mal Johnny hinterher gucken, was da los ist.
Was macht Johnny da?
Oh, was?
Ich rede nicht mit ihm.
Ich rede nicht mit emo Teenager.
Grammatik mein lieber Watson.
Sei bloß ruhig, Grammatik ist ja nicht mal ein ganzer Satz.
Lass uns einfach Momentos schauen.
Äh, nein.
Damen-Toilette?
Herren-Toilette?
Was macht denn Johnny da?
Lass mich raten.
Johnny wartet auf River und River ist nicht gekommen.
Huh?
Das klingt doch passend.
Okay, die Typen haben alle nichts mit der Story zu tun.
Das sind die dritte Person, die du entfernt hast.
Ja, ist doch egal, können wir immer noch gesetten.
Äh, Moment.
Nochmal Johnny.
Doppel Johnny.
Versetzt worden.
Du kannst dich gut in deinesgleichen einfühlen, wie ich sehe.
Okay, was muss ich denn machen?
Äh, Dr. Watson ist so ein Spaß.
Huh, hier ist nichts.
Tut mir leid, das sagen zu müssen, aber ich fürchte, wir müssen ihn noch ein bisschen ausfüllen.
Okay.
Huh, hier ist nichts. Tut mir leid, das sagen zu müssen, aber ich fürchte, wir müssen ihn noch mal ausquetschen.
Viel Erfolg. Wenigstens sind hier diesmal keine Oliven.
Johnny ist auf jeden Fall nicht gut drauf.
River!
Du warst die ganze Zeit da drin?
Ich hab im Foyer auf dich gewartet, ich dachte schon, du wärst nicht gekommen.
Warum bist du rausgegangen? Ich dachte, wir wollen den Film gemeinsam sehen.
Was? Das sollte ich dich fragen. Ja, für River ist das ganz klar, sie sitzen gemeinsam drinnen und gucken den Film.
Man muss nicht zusammen sitzen, um den Film zu gucken, man kann im gleichen Raum sitzen, um den Film zu gucken, das reicht.
In Rivers Logik ist das vollkommen klar.
Wie meinst du das?
Wir haben den Film noch zusammen angeschaut und plötzlich bist du rausgegangen.
Wir haben ihn nicht zusammen angeschaut. Ich wusste noch nicht mal, dass du da bist.
Wenn du mich gesehen hast, warum bist du nicht zu mir gekommen?
Was macht das für einen Unterschied? Ich mein, wir wollten uns den Film zusammen angucken.
Wir haben uns den selben Film, den selben Raum angeschaut.
Tja, Johnny.
Was hast du? Du bist so merkwürdig.
Möchtest du den Film jetzt nicht mehr mit mir zusammen anschauen?
Klar will ich das. Komm, lass uns reingehen, bevor es vorbei ist.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich sollte jetzt eine clevere Bemerkung machen.
Nein, dein Gefühl täuscht dich. Hoffentlich wartet ihr in die nächste Mitfahrgelegenheit.
Gehen wir rein. Nee, hier dürfen wir nicht rein, jetzt dürfen wir nur da rein.
Zack, fertig. Da ist ja wieder das Plüschtier.
Das Plüschtier schnabelt hier. Das ist verdammt krass.
Das Plüschtier schnabelt hier. Das ist erstaunlich oft am Start.
Ich habe vergessen, was es damit auf sich hat. Ich bin jetzt genauso gespannt wie ihr.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was damit gewesen ist.
Nein. Verdammt, kein Big Prane.
Okay, fast. Fast Big Prane.
Okay, ich bin jetzt am Ende.
Ich bin jetzt am Ende.
Ich bin am Ende.
Okay, fast, fast, Big Brain.
Aktivieren.
Wenn ich ehrlich bin, ich glaube, dieses Schnabeltier wächst mir so langsam ans Herz.
Hauptsächlich aus praktischen Gründen, aber immerhin.
River, in der Schule.
Komm schon Junge, hast du keine Eier?
Doch das schon, hör mal, vielleicht war das doch keine so tolle Idee.
Ach guck mal, da ist Nick wieder am Start, ach Gott, was soll denn schon passieren?
Denk doch mal nach, das Schlimmste, was passieren kann, ist, sie sagt nein.
Du schlenderst weiter, als ob nichts wäre, niemand wird jemals etwas erfahren, alle halten
dich immer noch für cool.
Man's not hot, und wenn sie jemanden davon erzählt, oder mich anschreit, jetzt reiß
dich mal zusammen, du Arschlamm, oder wenn sie ja sagt, was mache ich dann, aber eigentlich
nein mein, jetzt mach mal Haltlein, wer tut denn sowas?
Und wenn sie mir eine Enzyklopädie ins Gesicht schmeißt, ich hab nicht mal ein Helm dabei,
oh Gott, ich bin so dermaßen schlecht vorbereitet.
Alter, keine Panik, Bauch rein, Brust raus, und hör auf dich wie ein Arschlamm aufzuführen,
genau, sag ihm wo es lang geht.
Alles wird gut, dreh dich einfach um.
Alles klar, alles klar.
Ja, die Sache mit den Grills, hey, was tust du, pst, auf geht's Johnny, komm, gib alles,
äh, ich bin Johnny, hallo, mein Name ist Johnny, ich komm hier zufällig vorbei, hallo, kannst
du mich hören, ja, na klar, wieso hast du da nicht, äh, egal, ganz schön cooles Schnabeltier
hast du, das ist der krasseste Anmachspruch, den ich je gehört hab, Johnny, der ist fast
so gut, wie kannst du schwimmen, ich würd dich gerne ins, nein, nein, egal, das, nein,
was liest du da, ein Buch, über Schnabeltiere, nein, oh, das, äh, finde ich toll, über
Leuchttürme, wenn River wüsste, dass sie später mal einen eigenen Leuchtturm hat,
hä, es gibt noch genau 16 Leuchttürme mit Fernsehschen, Linsen, Zweiter Ordnung in
unserem Land, jawoll, ich mein, das ist allgemein bekannt, oder, das wusste man, weiß man,
neun von ihnen sind an der Küste und einer war vor seinem Umbau ein historischer Leuchtturm
mit Kerosinlampe, achso, darum geht es in deinem Buch, äh, sag mal, möchtest du vielleicht
irgendwann mit mir zusammen ins Kino einen Film ansehen, ich weiß nicht, schon okay,
du kannst in Ruhe drüber nachdenken, kann ich nicht, äh, warum, kein Datum, keine Uhrzeit,
ja, River ist da halt sehr konkret und direkt, oh, naja, äh, wie wäre es an diesem Samstag
um 8, äh, äh, Eva, ich glaube, das System hängt, ja, jawoll, ich nehme an, die Einzelheiten
klären wir dann später, guck mal, wie sie sogar hingekriegt haben, dass River ein bisschen
schüchtern guckt, ähm, tja, ich, ich gehe mal, hä, was schaust du mich so erwartungsvoll
an, äh, du meinst sicher, dass ich jetzt noch einmal ausspreche, wie unglaublich peinlich
diese Vorstellung war, vergiss es, den Gefallen werde ich dir nicht tun, lass ihn doch, er
war eben noch ein Kind, gerade du solltest ja wissen, wie man sich da fühlt, was, wie,
was heißt, was soll das heißen, halt die Klappe, wir müssen weiter, halt die Klappe
ist nicht mein Name, ein Schnabelplüschtier, ein hässliches Schnabelplüschtier, was zum
Teufel war das denn, Mann, wieso, ich hab mich verabredet, oh, das war erbärmlich,
an deiner Stelle wäre ich da einfach reingeplatzt und hätte die Kleine sofort abgecheckt und
weggecockt, ungefähr so, hey du, ausgeh'n, ich, du, jetzt, das ist einfach schrecklich,
ich weiß, aber es wäre immer noch besser als das, was du gerade durchgezogen hast, hat
sie dir ein Enzyklometin ins Gesicht geschmissen, nein, halt die Klappe, Mann, alter, piss dich,
siehst du, ich bin nicht der einzige, ich bin nicht der einzige, der Leute immer sagen
muss, wenn sie die Klappe halten, wie konnte ich mich nur von dir überreden lassen, in
dieses dämliche Fach zu gehen, ach komm, stell dich nicht an, das macht Spaß, nur weil
man malen kann, das sieht ein bisschen aus wie, ja, keine Ahnung, bisschen wie die heavy
freezing cat, falls ihr noch jemand kennt, Übung macht den Meister, klar, sicher, nach
diesem Schuljahr werde ich nie wieder einen Pinsel in die Hand nehmen, Fenris Blue, ja,
das sagen wirklich Leute, ernsthaft, so blöds klingt, das ist, glaubt das nicht, aber gibt
es, hör auf zu mosern, ich bin mir sicher, du wirst lernen, das zu mögen, wie, dafür
gab es kein Memory Link, TF, 10 Memory Link, Leonardo da Vinci hat geübt, indem er Eier
malte, Fässer sind wie sehr große Eier, klingt logisch, so gesehen werdet ihr alle
sehr große Da Vincis, natürlich, was sonst, ist hier irgendwas, niemand, guck mal Johnny
und River, wirklich niemand, wenn das so ist, River, warum gibst du uns nicht die Antwort,
äh, ich weiß, dass du die Antwort kennst, wir warten, River, na schön, er stach am 3.
August 1942 in See, geht es um Kolumbus, 1492 in See, von der spanischen Stadt Palos de
la Frontera aus, die 1322 gegründet wurde und an, ja blablabla, ist gut, ist gut, ich
wollte nur das Datum, seht ihr, das war jetzt so, war das jetzt so schwer, haben alle Leute
ein so fotografisches Gedächtnis, nicht wirklich, obwohl ich glaube, das hier Mustergedächtnis
oft sehr ausgeprägt ist, Achtung, sie kommt zu uns rüber, Alt-Tap, Alt-Tap, gucken sie
sich Brann an oder was, in der Schule, Alt-Tap, was ist die Notiz zu Alt-Tap, Moment, Lebensretter,
da ist was dran, da ist was dran, abgeschlossen, nur in der Mittagspause geöffnet, geht es
dann weiter, da, wie wärs, beim nächsten Mal solltet ihr Flaschen mal besser etwas
besser sein, eine Aula, die können wir für später gebrauchen, ich kann nicht glauben,
dass die Spielfeldmarkierungen in seinem Kopf rechteckig sind, das stimmt, na gut, der
Johnny hat wahrscheinlich nie wieder Basketball gespielt, John, na schön, du hast gewonnen,
jawoll, yeah, ah, es ist Mittagspause, weil da alle hinrennen, ja, es ist Mittagspause,
hallo, Morbid Martin, klar ist sie was besonderes, besonders langweilig, ich meine, schauen sie
noch mal an, ist voll niedlich, ich weiß gar nicht, was die alle haben, wie sie da sitzt
allein den ganzen Tag mit dieser gruselig deformierten Ente als Plüschtier, das ist
keine deformierte Ente, das ist ein Schnabeltier, Nick, ein was, hör auf, die Tiere auszudecken,
Nick hat nicht so big brain, wie auch immer, sie ist so dermaßen nebender Spur, als wäre
sie von einem anderen Planet oder so, ich weiß, ist das nicht cool, äh sicher, wenn
man auf Aliens und solches Zeug steht, dann wahrscheinlich schon, aber mal im Ernst, wenn
du durchgeknallt sein willst, warum hängst du nicht einfach mit den Emos und Gothic rum,
aha, naja, zum einen will ich mir nicht die Haare ruinieren und die Tatsache, dass wir
schon unsere Schubladen für sie haben, macht es nicht besser, sieh mal, Nick, ich will
einfach kein durchschnittlicher Junge in einem Ozean durchschnittlicher Leute sein, da sagt
Johnny was, warum zur Hölle sollte es denn deine Identität ändern, mit ihr zusammen
zu sein, ich meine, du wärst dann einfach ein Typ, der mit einem schüchternen Mädchen
drum hängt, sie ist nicht einfach nur schüchtern, Nick, irgendwas an ihr ist anders, ne anders
zu sein ist auch nicht immer so toll, weißt du denn überhaupt, ob sie wirklich will, weißt
du denn überhaupt, ob sie das wirklich will anders sein, vielleicht will sie einfach
nur dazugehören, so wie alle anderen auch, wir wissen mittlerweile, das möchte Riffa
ganz bestimmt nicht, und wenn das so ist, wärs nicht hilfreich, sie in die andere Richtung
zu drängen, oder, hör mal, Nick, die Sache ist die, ich weiß, was ich brauche, der John
kennt sich aber aus, und dieses Mädchen hat es, na, der ist aber für sein Alter schon
gut dabei, der Johnny, also willst du sie, weil sie etwas hat, aber nicht um ihr selbst
will, sehr philosophisch für die Schule, das ist eiskalt, man, ich hoffe nur, du weißt,
was du tust, ich weiß es, ich glaube übrigens, du hast Unrecht, die Menschen sind nicht
durchschnittlich, jeder ist auf seine Art etwas besonderes, das erzählen doch nur irgendwelche
Omas, guck mal, seine Tasche, die hat er später immer noch, Moment mal, dieser Typ ist so
eine Art Hipster, der sich an andere Menschen dranwandt, das ist irgendwie verstörend,
ich weiß, Little Samson, keine Ahnung, ob die 13, 14 sind, also, ich würd mal sagen,
ja, oder vielleicht 16, 17, weißt du, manchmal möchte ich unsere Kunden ein ordentliches
Kopfloss verpassen, so ist die Highschool, so ist die Highschool, jeder ist ein Spast,
aber hey, willkommen im Club, heißt das, Sebaros sagt, heißt das, dass Johnny River nur will,
weil sie nicht wie alle andere 0815 Menschen sein will, sieht aktuell so aus, aber wie
gesagt, am Ende ergibt das alles wunderbar Sinn, warte mal, darum ging es also bei dem
Gespräch an der Klippe, was an der Klippe hat er ihr erzählt, warum er sich an sie
dran gemacht hat, oder wie war das jetzt, vermutlich, dann kriegte sie einen Sprung in der Schüssel
und begann diese unheimlichen Hasen zu basteln, stimmt's, weil er ihr die ewig zurückliegende
Sache gebeichtert hat, man könnte sie durchaus als nachtragend bezeichnen, übrigens Nick,
Nick spoilern hier, ich sag's nochmal, falls du das Game kennst, nein, mein Gefühl sagt
mir, dass da noch mehr ist, dann hol schon mal deinen Hut, Sherlock, komm, ich glaube,
unsere Mitfahrgelegenheit lehnt da vorne am Tisch, ich brauch noch ein Momento, wo hab
ich das vergessen, Lelouch Ove, hi, guck mal ob River vielleicht noch ein Momento hat,
wie viele von diesen Pärchen bleiben zusammen schon länger als ein, äh, welche, wie viele
von diesen Pärchen, oh, ich kann nicht mehr lesen, wie viele von diesen Pärchen bleiben
heute schon länger als ein Monat zusammen, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir war, mit meinen
Mädels lief es damals alles glatt, ja, Watz ist klar, aha, so glatt, dass sie mir im Handumdrehen
alle wieder hinklitten, klingt als könnte das stimmen, ah, nice, oh nein, jetzt kommt
wieder irgendein Spruch, oh nein, ich wusste es, ich wusste es, Doktor Watz, ruined, uncool
Eva, WTF, nochmal, man stört niemals jemand in seinem Kamehameha, äh, Morbid Martin,
sag mal, was hast du eigentlich mittlerweile für eine Internetleitung, ich hab VDSL 100,
what, vorbereiten, weiter gehts, jetzt nähern wir uns langsam Johnnys Kindheit, wo wir dann
endlich verstehen, was eigentlich mit Johnny und River und was da eigentlich los ist, äh,
ich klick jetzt einfach mal, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man es eigentlich lösen müsste,
so, hm, big brain, intuitive hier, Intuition, big brain, keine Ahnung, was ich sagen wollte,
ähm, weiter, hi, hast du schon Battaglia und Battaglia 1944 versucht, noch nicht versucht,
ich dachte es kommt erst nächste Woche oder so, funktioniert bei dir Shadowplay, ja, Qualität
ist übel scheiße, du musst die Qualität hochstellen in den Settings, die, die, die, mit wieviel
AMBIT da aufnimmt, wo sind wir hier jetzt, so, Mama, ich geh jetzt zur Schule, machs gut,
Joey, ich hab dir schon mal durchgespielt, feelsBatman, ja, vor drei Jahren oder so,
so genau kann ich mich da nicht mehr dran erinnern, ich weiß nur, dass die Story wirklich
herzzerreißend war, mein kleiner Junge, er wird so schnell erwachsen, auf gehts, Johnny,
Moment, hat sie, hat sie wieder Joey gesagt, mein Gott, und wenn er ein Mädchen wäre,
würde sie ihn dann auch mit dem Namen seines Großvaters ansprechen, stimmt, sie nennt
ihn ja nicht, sie nennt ihn ja Joey und nicht Johnny, ich überlese das immer, ich lese
das zu schnell, die Mutter sagt ja zu Johnny immer Joey, das wäre gar nicht mal so schlimm,
er endet immerhin auf I, Joey, Jouei, Jouel, G, ja, genau, wenn das so knuffig klingt wie
so heiratest du nicht einfach, eifersüchtig, was, oh ja extrem eifersüchtig, hier gibt
es doch ein Fußball, den können wir noch nicht, eine Uhr die tickt, eine tickende Uhr,
keiner wer echt auf die Nerven geht, da hat er recht, was, was haben wir hier, das Gurkenglas
wieder, nicht schon wieder, ein Glas eingelegte Gurken, du bist ziemlich leicht zu beeindrucken,
es gibt hier oben diverse Bücher mit unleserlichen Titeln, gibt es hier sonst noch was, nee ne,
hab ich irgendwas vergessen, hab ich, hab ich irgendwas übersehen, irgendwas hab ich
übersehen, ach hier, schade dass du keine PS4 hast, sonst könntest du The Last Guardian
spielen Max, ist von der Story her ganz großes Kino, ich hab ne PS4, seit Release hab ich
ne PS4, das wollte ich auch noch mal spielen, The Last Guardian, ich hab Ico gespielt,
ich hab Shadow of the Colossus gespielt, was ja so quasi die zwei, äh, zwei Vorgänger
wenn man so will waren, so Big Brain Plays wieder, easy, so jetzt wollen wir mal gucken
was in Johnnys Kindheit so passiert ist, äh, es riecht nach Verwesung, wo sind wir, was
sieht nicht wie Johnnys Kindheit aus, Eva, WTF ist das, was macht das in Johnnys Gedanken
ohne Johnnys Erinnerung, seine nächste Erinnerung, schön aber warum sieht hier, was, schön aber
warum sieht, siehts hier aus wie in Laputa aus, gute Frage, die Erinnerungen verbinden
sich nicht richtig miteinander, muss ich wohl um eine Fehlfunktion der Maschine handeln,
schon wieder, beim letzten Update war die Behauptung sie sei nun für mindestens ein
halbes Jahr ioten sicher, äh, unsere IT Abteilung besteht aus lauter Schwachköpfen, egal halb
so schlimm, die Teenager Zeit haben wir ja abgespeichert, damit könnten wir es schon
hinkriegen, in Ordnung aber ich werde ihm nichts über das hier erzählen, solange wir
erfolgreich sind, muss er es auch nicht erfahren, tja, ich glaube das wars, wir können hier
nichts tun, so einfach ist es nicht, bereit für die Finalisierung, ladies first, zu schade,
ich hätte gern mehr erfahren, oh wir erfahren auch noch mehr, wir erfahren alles, zweite
Akt, Milliarden von Leuchttürmen, die fest sitzen am anderen Ende des Himmels, oh ich
weiß nicht, wo hier Social heulen angesagt ist, halten sie mit Abstand, sie werden nicht
einfach aufwachen, aber sie brauchen volle Konzentration, jetzt sind wir wieder beim
alten Johnny, und das ist alles was ich als alter Narbe weiß, tja tut mir leid, ich bin
wohl keine große Hilfe, dann muss das so reichen, ok jetzt müssen wir nur noch den Wunsch mit
ihren frühesten Kindheitserinnerungen verbinden, dann legen wir den Schalt da oben und zack
im Handnotdrehen stehen sie auf dem Mond, ich hab eine Frage, wenn sie Lily verschwinden
lassen können, dann bedeutet das, dass sie die Welt verändern können, warum tun sie
das nicht einfach noch einmal und erfüllen mir meinen Wunsch gleich hier und jetzt, das
würde funktionieren, wenn dies ihre wahren Erinnerungen wären, was soll das heißen,
was ist das hier denn, was bin ich, nur eine Kopie, eine Leinwand auf der wir arbeiten
wenn sie es so wollen, was sie selbst angeht, sie sind nur ein Algorithmus, abgeleitet aus
Johnny, gut genug für ein Abbild von ihm, aber längst nicht vollständig, äh wer ist
Lily, Lily ist seine Betreuerin, seine Altenpflegerin, alles was wir tun können ist dieses Bild auf
logische Weise schlüssig zu ergänzen, wie ich einfach die Hälfte der Dialoge nicht
richtig vorlese, wenn wir dann ihren Wunsch in ihrer Kindheit übertragen, generiert die
Maschine ein neues Leben für sie, eines in dem dieser Wunsch in Erfüllung geht, dieses
Ergebnis schreiben wir dann in das Gedächtnis des echten Johnnys, sie sehen also, selbst
wenn sie zufrieden mit uns sind, bleiben sie doch nur ein Read-Only-Programm, ich meine
wir können sie resetten so oft wir wollen und das reicht, ach sei nicht so empfindlich,
es ist eh nicht real, wenn du das wirklich glaubst, warum machst du dir so viel Mühe
es ihm zu erklären, ich versuche nur Zeit zu sparen, gehen wir, Doktor, ist es das was
ich wirklich bin?
die Arbeit einer ganzen Nacht, da geht es nicht weiter, WTF, du hättest mich wenigstens
vorwarten können, dass du noch als Kopf herumschwebst, ich kann es nicht leugnen, ich gehe einfach
gerne mit dem Kopf voran, ich würde ja fragen, ob das ein Scherz sein soll, aber ich habe
Angst vor der Antwort, ziehen wir es durch, ich komme mir in dieser Gestalt dumm genug
vor, alles was wir tun müssen ist seinen Wunsch von der spätesten Erinnerung zur frühesten
zu transferieren, ok jetzt kommen komische Schiebespielchen, ich meine das war doch relativ
simpel, ja ich weiß noch wie das funktioniert, das war ziemlich simpel, glaube ich dass das
irgendwie so ging, man muss es jetzt einfach durchleiten, das war nicht sonderlich schwierig,
ach ne Moment, so einfach ist es doch nicht, wenn ich das jetzt rumdrehe, oh Gott Logik
Spielchen, wenn ich das jetzt rumdrehe passt das hier nicht mehr, moment easy, fangen wir
links an, ok hier ist eine Uhr, das einzige was sich hier deckt ist die Uhr und das heißt
ich muss die Uhr auf jeden Fall auf diese Seite machen, was anderes bleibt mir nicht
übrig, so funktioniert das ganze nicht, hey Eva guck mal, der Typ, oh Mann, wenn ich
transferiere in die falsche Richtung, ich noob, hallo Yoshi 1297, so es kann doch nicht so
schwierig sein, so hier rumdrehen, easy, next, was gibt es hier, was hier gleich ist, das
Buch, ok, das heißt das Buch muss auf jeden Fall auf die linke Seite, sonst geht es nicht
weiter, so wenn das Buch auf die linke Seite muss, dann muss der Hase auch auf die linke
Seite und da, was, ok dann geht es nur so, was, hä, Moment, Moment, ich hab das gar
nicht gelöst jetzt, egal, das Game meint, ich hab's gelöst, ist alles gut, easy, Ding,
so das wären dann alle mit denen wir arbeiten können, bereit auf den Knopf zu drücken,
du kennst mich doch, ich bin immer bereit, alles klar, dann schauen wir mal, was für
Souvenirs Johnny uns vom Mond mitgebracht hat, ladies first, diesmal nicht süße, dann gucken
wir mal ob Johnny jetzt auf dem Mond war, das hier ist dasselbe Umgebung wie in der
letzten echten Erinnerung auf die wir Zugriff haben, normalerweise müsste sich doch wenigstens
etwas geändert haben, irgendwas stimmt nicht, diese Erinnerungen, sie fühlen sich nicht
so an als wären sie einfach noch einmal passiert, sie sind exakt die gleichen, unmöglich, das
verlangen wurde doch transferiert zum Mond zu fliegen oder etwa nicht, doch wurde es,
aber es funktioniert nicht, warum funktioniert das nicht, das ist genau das gleiche wieder,
Johnny, was für eine schöne Überraschung, wir haben seltenen Besuch, das ist genau das
gleiche, mein Name ist Doktor Eva Rosalin und das ist, was ich sage das jetzt nicht
zweimal, Doktor Niall Watts, ist ihnen der Name Siegmund Agency of Life Generation geläuflich,
oh ja, also sie beiden sind von der Agentur, das ist genau das gleiche nochmal, das trifft
sich gut, ich habe gerade überlegt sie anzurufen, Lilly bring uns doch bitte etwas Tee, zack,
also es hat sich nichts geändert, friere ihn auch ein, und jetzt, warte hier, ich gehe
jetzt und sende das Verlangen Signal noch einmal, pass auf ob sich etwas ändert, die
Übertragung war definitiv erfolgreich, hat sich etwas geändert, nicht einmal ein bisschen,
wie ist das möglich, selbst wenn das Verlangen alleine nicht ausreicht, warum ändert sich
dann gar nichts, vielleicht braucht es einfach etwas Stimulation um in Gang zu kommen, aus
seinen frühen Erinnerungen, so früh wir zurück gehen können, ja auf gehts, hallo Cheesy Pro,
Johnnys Wunsch zum Mond zu fliegen braucht etwas Stimulation, also dann, oh wir stimulieren,
Moon, was zum, an der Kasse haben sie gesagt, dass ein anderer Film läuft, egal, macht
es dir was aus River, nein ich mag diesen auch, ok dann lass uns reingehen, sie versuchen
ihm jetzt irgendwie einzuhämmern, dass er zum Mond fliegen will und Astronaut wird,
hoffentlich reicht das für die Zündung, Moment, wo ist eigentlich Nile, hier ist er
noch nicht, was gibt das jetzt, zum Mond Liebling, oh Henry, was ist das für ein Film, ok ich
bin viel zu angespannt, wahrscheinlich sollte ich mal nachsehen, ob sich bei Johnn irgendwas
verändert hat, lass mich schreien, es hat sich nichts geändert, alles unverändert,
ich muss versuchen irgendwie das anders zu machen, vielleicht kann man hier etwas versuchen,
was macht eigentlich der Schnabeltier, steht da rum, was macht ihr denn noch hier, es geht
gleich los, wenn wir uns nicht beeilen sind die guten Plätze weg, ok dann werden wir ihm
jetzt beibringen, dass er auf den Mond, dass er Astronaut werden soll, das habe ich anders
erinnert, es muss sich was verändert haben, hey nicht drängeln, da macht Nile jetzt bestimmt
irgendwie ne Show oder sowas, Moment mal, das ist keine echte Änderung, darf ich um
eure Aufmerksamkeit bitten, wie ihr wisst bin ich Repräsentant der Chloriosen der Haza
und ich bin heute hier um euch alles darüber zu erzählen, hau rein Timmy, aber ich schweife
ab, sie wollen mich jetzt ernsthaft einreden lassen, wie auch immer, ich weiß, dass sich
viele von euch eine Frage stellen, wie groß ist die Chance, dass ich jemals etwas großartiges
machen kann, wie zu einem Abenteuer in neue Welten aufzubrechen, den süßen Duft der
Venuschnuppern gegen den Uhrzeigersinn durch die Ringe des Saturns zu schwimmen oder vielleicht
einfach ein bisschen auf der dunklen Seite des Mondes abzuhängen, wir von der NASA glauben,
dass jeder dazu das Zeug kann, wenn er sich nur richtig anstrengt, du könntest es sein,
oder du, oder vielleicht du, das wird auch nicht funktionieren, aber ich möchte gar
nicht zum Mond, sogar Johnny sagt hier zu dem Zeitpunkt, er will nicht zum Mond, dann
ist heute dein Glückstag, Moment was, wieso nicht, wieso willst du nicht zum Mond, was
soll ich da, ah zu diesem Zeitpunkt willst Johnny auch nicht auf den Mond, ich bin glücklich
hier auf der Erde, du willst überhaupt nicht hin, nicht mal ein kleines bisschen auf den
Mond, nein, warum, nicht mal ein kleines bisschen, äh, ne,
nun als offizieller NASA-Rekrutierungsoffizier erzähle ich dir jetzt ein paar unglaubliche
Fakten über den Mond, sehts dreht da auf, um warm zu werden, der Mond ist 4,5 Milliarden
Jahre alt, Residenz-Liefer, Residenz-Liefer und wusstet ihr, dass seine Oberfläche so groß
wie der afrikanische Kontinent ist, doch wirklich, wenn ich das, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla,
es wird Johnny nicht überzeugen, und weiter, das Licht braucht, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla
und ja, das wusste ich schon, und das Beste zu plus, Leute, die zum Mond fliegen werden
reich und berühmt und wir alle kennen die Gleichung, reich plus berühmt gleich Groupies,
denkt dran, bei der NASA seid ihr alle willkommen, besonders daran, wenn ihr prünett seid, es
zieht alles nicht bei Johnny, Johnny will nicht mehr zum Mond, zumindest kleiner Johnny
will nicht zum Mond, na, wie war ich, die NASA wird dich wahrscheinlich nicht anheuern,
ich habe alles gegeben, willst du mal nachsehen, ob es was gebracht hat, natürlich, bin gleich
zurück, es hat natürlich nichts gebracht, ne, wenn ich jetzt mal rate, bin zurück, erzähl,
grandioser Filmschlag, Facepalm, nicht gut, hey, lasst dich nicht entmutigen, ich bin
sicher, dass wir immer noch was machen können, und das wäre, tja, wir können uns nicht leisten,
dieses Haus fertig zu bauen, Isabelle, er will ihn wirklich krampfhaft davon überzeugen,
aber können sie sich die Mondlandungslotterie leisten, er will ihn ernsthaft überzeugen,
um den Mond zu fliegen, aber er will nicht, die Diagnose steht fest, ja, genau genommen
haben wir nur selten, hey, wussten sie, dass die Mitarbeiter der NASA exzellente Krankenversicherungsleistung
bekommen, tatsächlich, sie beide und ihre Liebste, Polly reiten für lau im All, es
zieht alles nicht, zieht mal alle eine Hochzeit, tolle Sache, wir sind von der NASA, ratet mal,
wo ihr ganz mondän Flitterwochen machen könnt, es zieht einfach nicht, Johnny will nicht,
so, verdammt rutschig, Johnny, was zur Gurke, ha, knapp, weißt du was, es klappt einfach
nicht, das ist mehr als einfach nicht klappen lassen, das ist lächerlich, wir sind Profis,
verdammt, ich mach diesen Job nicht, um die Gegend zu rennen und Leute anzuschreien, nicht,
ich glaube, es liegt einfach an unserem verdammt langen Tag, hätte ich gewusst, dass wir die
Nacht durcharbeiten, hätte ich Kaffee mitgenommen, absolut, du hattest mal den Film sehen sollen,
den ich vorhin verbrochen habe, welcher Film, siehst du, das meine ich, so kostbar unsere
Zeit hier auch ist, in diesem Zustand kommen wir einfach nicht weiter, machen wir Pause
bis morgen früh, hoffentlich hält Johnny bis dahin durch, ich muss ein paar Anrufe
machen, Gigi Eats.
Das macht keinen Sinn, wieso hat die Maschine nicht funktioniert, Johnnys Wunsch zum Mond
zu fliegen wurde erfolgreich übertragen und trotzdem gab es nach dem Transfer kein
einziges Anzeichen dafür, dass er zum Mond wollte, es sei denn, eine zweite Bedingung
für seine Sehnsucht wurde dabei mit geändert, nur dann könnte der gleiche Wunsch zu zwei
verschiedenen Ergebnissen an unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten führen, ohne Zweifel spielt
River eine wichtige Rolle bei der ganzen Sache, wenn es also irgendwas gibt, was diese Veränderung
verursacht haben kann, dann wäre sie die Hauptverdächtige, aber was genau ist die
Ursache, River, was genau hast du getan, sie baut Papierhasen und wir wissen immer noch
nicht warum, ah die Sonne geht auf, wir haben nicht mal viel Zeit, ich frage mich ob Nile
etwas herausgefunden hat, so wie ich Nile kenne, wahrscheinlich nicht, außer dumme Sprüche
zu machen, wie geht, man kann als Eichhörnchen bis hierher riechen, wo ist Nile jetzt, stellst
er hier irgendwo rum, ne, wie geht es John, wir verlieren ihn, was treiben sie dann, wir
sind einfach nicht vorwärts gekommen, tun sie etwas, wir haben nicht mal viel Zeit,
falls sie ihren Kollegen suchen, er ist in der Küche, okay, man ist die Küche hier,
ach guck mal, das sind die leeren Bilder, wo Johnny vorhin davor stand, und da ist auch
dieses komische Schnabel hier wieder drauf, scheint ja echt wichtig zu sein, ist die Küche
hier gewesen, oder ist die Küche unten, ne, das ist das Klo, aber das ist kein 3000 Euro
Klo, das habe ich gleich fachmännischem Blick analysiert, wo ist denn Nile, wie heißt er
eigentlich, hast du Nile, hast du Nile, da ist er, nein den Teil verstehe ich, aber okay,
hast du das in den Akten gecheckt, und warum nochmal wurden uns diese Informationen verschwiegen,
oder dem Arzt in diesem Fall, vorher hast du den Kaffee, sprichst du mit der Zentrale,
ja, ich erkläre es dir später, also Ruhe, okay, was mache ich jetzt, bis Nile fertig
telefoniert hat, wo geht es denn hier lang, wir gehen mal kurz durchs Haus ein bisschen
gucken, das Bad, wo sind eigentlich die Kinder, aber Mama, ich will nicht zur Schule, es ist
Sonntag, easy, lass sie schlafen, ich sag nix, gibt es hier irgendwas, Buch ins Regal,
okay, wann ist Nile fertig telefoniert, ist er fertig, was hat denn Lilly zu der ganzen
Sache zu sagen, hallo, ich will mit dir reden, die Kinder sollten doch zeitig ins Bett gehen,
ja, nehmen Platz, ich glaube ich hab sie verbackt, Truhe ist verschlossen, ha, kriegt man das
auf, oh wollen sie mich noch was fragen, Lilly, Tommy, ehrlich gesagt nicht, oh hey, also
vielen Dank, gucken wir mal, ob Nile fertig telefoniert ist, ja Eva, geh da mal rein, hm,
was ist, erscheinen als gäbe es vertrauliche Akten zu Johnnys Kindheit, vertrauliche, vertrauliche
Krankenakten, um genau zu sein, offenbar hat er während seiner Kindheit eine nicht unbeträchtliche
Menge an Beta Blockern verabreicht bekommen, und was für ein Zufall, die haben ein kleines
bisschen Nebenwirkung auf so komische Dinge namens Gedächtnis, Beta Blocker, Johnny
hatte keine Herzprobleme, oder, anscheinend nicht, was uns zur Frage führt, ob diese Nebenwirkungen
nicht die eigentliche Absicht waren, vor allem bei derart großen Mengen, der Einfluss
auf sein Erinnerungsvermögen muss immens gewesen sein, du meinst, das hat uns den Weg
zu den Kindheitserinnerungen versperrt, das ist jedenfalls kein Maschinenfehler, so viel
kann ich dir sagen, die IT-Abteilung hat ganz schön, was, die IT-Abteilung hat mich ganz
schön angemolzt, weil ich sie beschuldigt habe, und was jetzt, na rein in die Maschine,
ich habe die Frequenz-Modifikationen bekommen, mit denen können wir die Barriere überwinden,
und wenn wir erstmal in seiner Kindheit angekommen sind, ist es sicher früh genug, um den Wunsch
erfolgreich zu übertragen, worauf warten wir dann, es gibt noch eine Sache, es gibt
immer noch eine Sache, um die neue Frequenz zu aktivieren, brauchen wir einen Auslöser,
ein Auslöser, etwas in den versperrten Erinnerungen, das sehr stark präsent ist, und wir müssen
es Tony geben, damit er seine Erinnerung wecken kann, und wie sollen wir das machen, wir wissen
so gut wie nicht über seine Kindheit, und selbst wenn wir ein Kindheitsfoto fänden,
Tony ist nach wie vor bewusstlos, ja also sind wir keinen Schritt weiter, weißt du, seit
in eures Fall letztes Jahr hatten wir keinen Auftrag mehr, der mich so saumäßig genervt
hat, geht mir genauso, das bringt mich nur um, ich gehe mal etwas frische Luft schnappen,
gut, nein, mach das, da ist er wieder, ähm, hab mein Kaffee vergessen, alter Laden, ich
gehe dem jetzt mal hinterher, es stinkt, ja nach dem Eichhörnchen, was er überfahren
hat, das überfahrene Tier, Eva, es stinkt, ich weiß, daran bist du schuld, du hast es
überfahren, was ist los, die Kinder schlafen noch, Moment mal, letzte Erinnerung, die wo
wir feststecken, sie hatte den selben Geruch, wie das überfahrene Tier,
worüber reden sie beide, er meint, dass der Geruchssinn wahrscheinlich der effektivste
Sinn ist, um Erinnerung zu wecken, alter wollen sie jetzt Johnny, Johnny hat noch 1-2 Tage
zu leben, ja, und sie wollen ihm ein verwestes Eichhörnchen aufs Bett legen, obwohl Johnny
bewusstlos ist, ist er immer noch empfänglich dafür, ich glaube, ich hab den Zusammenhang
nicht kapiert, ok, das ist gut, das ist fantastisch, jetzt muss ich nur mal was von dem überfahrenden
Eichhörnchen holen, ja, ich werde, Moment mal, warum sollte ich das hier holen, du hast
es überfahren, genau, ich habe meinen Beitrag geleistet, oh, du Spast, sie können meine
Handschuhe haben, es sind zwar eigentlich keine Wegwerfhandschuhe, aber das wird danach
vermutlich ändern, so, wir speichern mal, so, gehen wir das überfahrene Eichhörnchen
holen, guck, sie hat sogar Handschuhe an, oh man, soll ich jetzt da runterlaufen, noch
ein Eichhörnchen, hm, dann gehen wir mal das Eichhörnchen holen, es ist zu gefährlich,
naja, ok, dann schmeißen wir es in die Box, sie wollen allen Ernstes, schau dir den todlen
Eichhörnchen auf, naja, ihr wollt was, ihr wollt eine Pause machen, eh, dann geht mal
kurz aufs Klo, geht mal kurz aufs Klo, ich mach kurz Pause, ich denk mal das Spiel geht
wahrscheinlich noch so ne, wie lang wird, wie lang geht das ungefähr noch, ich würd
mal sagen so 45 Minuten, Stunde, Stunde, 45 Minuten bis Stunde, ja, auf gehts Leute,
kurz Pause, dann gehts weiter, geht mal alle aufs Klo, geh ich auch mal.
Ok, dann gehts weiter, ich mach kurz Pause, ich mach kurz Pause, ich denk mal das Spiel
gehts, ok, dann gehts weiter, ich mach kurz Pause, ich mach kurz Pause, ich denk mal
das Spiel gehts, ok, dann gehts weiter, ich mach kurz Pause, ich denk mal
so ich bin wieder am start ich warte jetzt noch ein zwei minuten dass die
leute wiederkommen können dann geht es weiter gerade mal kurz gucken was auf
youtube so abgeht wie mein neues video einfach schon mal 15k aufrufe innerhalb
von ein paar stunden hat einfach nur weil der cheater im titel steht aber
wollte ich das video gar nicht freischalten und 330 kommentare hat
lull eine minuten noch
ist ein gutes video mir hat mir hat die aufnahme nicht gefallen deswegen wollte
ich nicht freischalten ich weiß nicht ich glaube also warum ich das video heute
freigeschaltet habe ich glaube das problem war dass ich beim upload
normalerweise habe ich standardmäßig eingestellt dass beim video upload das
auf privat gestellt wird und aus irgendwelchen gründen habe ich
wahrscheinlich es nicht also irgendwie irgendwie von privat auf halt nicht mehr
privat gestellt beim upload und dann hat das video halt verarbeitet und sich
quasi nach dem verarbeiten selbst freigeschaltet deswegen hatte das video
auch kein titel und keine video beschreibung so richtig sondern sondern
halt nur so meine standard video beschreibung die ich rein mache dass ich
dran denke die links in die beschreibung zu kopieren und da auf gameplayer spieler
zu verlinken oder titel war ja auch einfach nur cheater punkt warf nicht
warf mkv
max wird mal indianer zukunft am video zum thema kryptowährung sehen
wahrscheinlich ja wahrscheinlich soll heute alle wieder da wo gehen sie hin
klopause ja das passt doch soll heute alle wieder am start
wann kommt der max fps koin ich bin ich bin eher der mein wer sollte die
bubblers koin machen das klingt viel besser weiter geht's willi wo gehen sie
hin ich für kleine doktoren der hat es aber
eigentlich pures kaos der aufbrach alles so hier aneinander geworfen mal sehen
kram kram kram hier ist die box hermetisch versiegelbare box erhalten
ja jetzt brauchen wir noch was von dem überfahrenden eichhörnchen
kommt noch mehr reinpacken ok dann gehen wir mal zurück zum haus und setzen
johnny der noch einen tag zu leben hat ungefähr ein verwestes eichhörnchen
teile von einem verwesen eichhörnchen aufs bett wie in echt also laut ich denke
das game dauert noch so ungefähr 45 minuten und das sind die schlimmsten
45 minuten es gibt kaum ein game was mich emotional so mitgenommen hat von
die letten wie die letzte stunde von im game hast du das überfahrene tier mit
gebracht alles bereit schön dann leg schon mal los ich bin gleich wieder da
wo gehst du hin ich muss ich muss meinen tamagotchi füttern was wort doch
wirklich schwester ich hatte eben so ein retro feeling wie auch immer weil ich
mache alles fertig ich bin 0,6 wieder da macht du mal weil ich da drüben stirbt
gleich jemand was hat er vor ich habe keine zeit hier hinterher zu
laufen wenn wir an exakt diesem punkt angekommen sind gebe ich das signal so
bald ich das tue öffnen sie mit das ventil für etwa drei sekunden ja wurde
aber auch zeit dass du auftauchst sicher dass keine keime entweichen können
alles versiegelt und durchgefiltert nicht dass es einem toten man noch viel aus
machen würde sie sollten wissen dass ich schon ist
zustand rapide verschlechtert es könnte ihre letzte chance sein was immer sie
beide da drin vor haben ich wünsche ihnen viel glück glück ist das letzte was
wir jetzt brauchen
jetzt geht es zur sache dritter akt sie senden ihr licht zu den atmen zu den
anderen leuchttürmen uns zu mir wir sind wieder bei johnny daheim gehen wir ja
hier haben wir aufgehört holt schon mal die taschentücher raus die letzte
stunde ist wirklich schlimm so ein kleines ding und es macht uns so viel
ärger ich könnte es zum mond schießen
lul schätze wir können jetzt nur noch das signal senden und hoffen gut bereit
ready so dann stinkt mal johnny mit dem eichhörnchen ein
irgendwas passiert schnell sende es noch mal was ist los
da stimmt was nicht wort übernehmen sie für mich lily
sei sein zustand hat sich destabilisiert ich muss die medikation anpassen
was passiert hier er ist instabil geworden raus hier was nein wir gehen
nicht raus raus aus einem gedächtnis sofort wieso solange das system so
instabil ist kann jeder das sich hier befindet bleiben schaden nehmen
du machst witz warum lockst du dich da nicht aus ich kann ich nahe wenn wir uns
beide auslangen ist unsere bisherige arbeit verloren warum auch immer und wir
haben nicht mehr genug zeig alles noch mal zu machen bevor johnny stirbt
ach du scheiße erzähl mir doch kein mist wir sind hier nicht im kinofilm du
bist nicht die heldin du bist einfach nur bescheuert aber du bist der held oder
wie macht dass du rauskommst vergiss es wenn du weg bist stecken sie mich
wahrscheinlich in ein team mit alice der ich verstehe die witz von eil nicht
weißt du wie der mann stinkt schlimmer als das überfahrene viel verdammt
das habe ich nun davon dass ich dir geholfen habe nicht durch den eignung
test zu muggeln und der doktor der hat sie gekriegt
übrigens im nachfolge ist der gleiche doktor am start sieht noch genauso aus
und heißt auch einfach nur doktor alles im griff vorerst
so haben wir es geschafft und weißt du was dein karottenkuchen ist ekelhaft ja
und bei der letzten weihnachtsfeier hattest du
komm lass uns gehen bevor das noch mal passiert weißt du ich habe das nicht
wirklich so gemeint also dass du bescheuert bist ich allerdings schon
da gucken wir mal jetzt an was in johnny's kindheit passiert ist
ich muss zum ball
augen zu und durch
wir haben es geschafft sind in johnny's kindheit es hat
funktioniert ich kann es kaum glauben wir sind also tatsächlich durch aber ich
bin mir nicht jetzt nicht mehr sicher ob es mir hier gefallen wird wieso sieht
doch alles ganz friedlich aus nein vorhin in johnny's zimmer ist jeder
selbst ist jeder etwas seltsames aufgefallen was denn da war etwas
seltsames hast du es nicht gesehen ich glaube nicht schon gut ich hoffe nur
dass ich unrecht habe
wo das klingt fabelhaft ich weiß ok irgendwann musst du mal musst du mich
mal da dort was irgendwann musst du sie mal dort mitnehmen ich kann ich mal
lesen die zeit überlappung gerät außer kontrolle
zieht ihr mal an wie viele exemplare von ihm hier sind es ist ein regelrechter
johnny zu da ist der ball johnny bleibst du stehen
sieht so bald es sieht so aus als würde man sich von alleine überwinden
guck mal ein eichhörnchen
sie man auf die uhr wir sind so spät dran ich war mich besser auf den weg das
geschäft macht heute früher zu pass auf dich auf grüß die jungs von mir
wach ich wir sehen uns
tja das ist wohl eine sackgasse und worauf wolltest du hinaus vergisst es
einfach vielleicht hatte ich auch mal unrecht schau nur dieser ort er ist so
friedlich in dieser erinnerung existiert nichts was etwa was so etwas auslösen
könnte außer verdammt wir müssen umkehren sofort
moment mal was was denn jetzt schon wieder halt einfach die klappe komm mit
ich verstehe das nicht er war bewusstlos wie können wir das hier sehen wenn er
selbst nicht einmal gesehen hat jedenfalls ist es ein wunder dass er
überlebt hat eigentlich hat er das ja auch gar nicht
ja wie kann schon die das nicht überlebt haben er ist ja noch da hast du
dir sein zimmer nicht angesehen nein johnny hat johnny hatte ein etagenbett
joey
joey kannst du mich hören deswegen nennt in seiner mutter auch
immer joey joey warum hast du joey überfahren mama ach das ist auch noch
die mutter
das habe ich beim ersten mal durchspielen gar nicht gecheckt
das ist die mutter von ihm auch noch als ergibt es ja noch mehr sind dass die
mutter ihn jetzt joey nennt
warum hast du ihn überfahren wach auf joey wach auf
joey geht der chat noch oder seid ihr alle so gespannt dabei und sagt nix auch
wenn sie noch so klein waren ein zwillingsbruder zu verlieren ganz davon
abgesehen wie sich die mutter fühlen musste
wenigstens hatte johnny die beta blocker um die erinnerung auszulöschen nicht
dass da noch viel wäre sie sind nur entkoppelt nicht gelöscht irgendwo hier
drin hat ein nachhalt dieser erinnerung wahrscheinlich weiter existiert wir
wissen übrigens immer noch nicht warum er zum mond will was ist mit der mutter
ich glaube nicht dass sie beta blocker genommen hat sieht aus als wäre sie ein
wenig durchgedreht zumindest glaube ich nicht mehr dass joey nur ihr
spitzname für johnny war aber wenn sie johnny als ersatz für joey nimmt was
ist dann mit johnny selbst
wir gefällt das hier nicht lass uns gehen das ist nicht die einzige
abgekoppelte erinnerung seltsam es baut keine barriere mehr auf mal nicht den
teufel an die wand kleiner johnny und joey man das muss unbedingt auch mal
lesen ich meine echt jetzt die serie ist einfach nur genial ich habe schon drei
bücher einfach so weggelesen johnny was liest du denn animos ja das fanden
joey später oder johnny später auch geil es geht um eine gruppe von kindern
die sich in tiere verwandeln und gegen schnecken kämpfen die deine gedanken
kontrollieren klingt eine tolle story ach diese seltsamen alien zeugs ist
nichts für mich wieso nicht es ist der hammer statt nur langweilig guckt euch
mal übrigens den rucksack an den hat er später immer noch statt zur
langweiligen schule zu gehen könnten sie die werden die große böse er sind
stöcke reißen dabei machen sie immer so ich mach das jetzt mal nicht nach so
wie tiger halt machen wenn man das schreibt und dann kriegen sie laser und
dann alle bähm in your face bähm bähm dass das lull du wirst schon sehen
johnny eines tages werde ich ein berühmter
autor dann schreibe ich die coolste geschichte überhaupt und alle kinder
kriegen ein buch umsonst ich werde uns reich machen dann kaufe ich dir und
mamma eine dicke villa wie willst du uns reich machen wenn die bücher umsonst
sind umsonst für die kinder die eltern müssen zahlen ist auch klar
klar ich bin ganz sicher dass die eltern dir das geld hinterher schmeißen werden
was ist bist du immer noch sauer wegen neulich jetzt komm schon ich habe als
erster gesagt dass ich den zug haben will zwar alles ganz fair was ist eigentlich
mit dem preis passiert was ist eigentlich mit deinem preis passiert
habe ich verschenkt an ein penner pass auf es geht nicht nur um neulich
du weißt dass du immer mammas liebling warst hey das ist doch gar nicht wahr
erinnerst du dich an letzte weihnachten und letzte ostern und als wir angel waren
und und und ok weißt du was du kannst mein zug haben wenn du willst
echt jetzt ja hier neben den zug ich meine nach deiner logik wird sie mir ja
einfach einen neuen kaufen oder
hör mal johnny welche unterschied macht es schon in wem von uns was gehört
alles was meinst ist auch deins ich meine wir können doch beide damit spielen
oder
stimmt siehst du ich meine du bist mein zwillingsbruder mann alter lan du bist
wie ein teil von mir ey komm lass uns die nachbarn ärgern
warte mal im regen klar auf geht's
animos
nicht genug memory links doch klar
so und jetzt werden wir langsam verstehen was sache ist da kann ich mich
noch dran erinnern das ist somit die schlüsselszene in
dem game so eine art jahrmarkt oder nicht sollen wir uns ein wenig umsehen
wie wäre es wenn ich mich um sehe und du hier einfach stehen bleibt wie wäre es
wenn wir uns eine stunde lang nur noch in frageform unterhalten auf zu quatschen
und gehe jetzt hast du es vermasselt
tomaten sind keine früchte nach haben sie auch eingelegte gurken ja ich will
jetzt nicht wissen was tomaten sind
kleiner johnny und kleiner joey aber ich will dieses blöde ding nicht ich will
den zug wir haben nur noch einen zug willst du deinen preis vielleicht statt
dessen gegen einen teddy bear tauschen nein ich will den zug na kommt schon
johnny mach keine szene joey hat ihn zuerst gewonnen fair und gerecht oder
einfach nicht aber ich habe auch gewonnen nur weil er vor mir dran war
lull ist schon okay du darfst auch damit spielen
siehst du wie nett von deinem bruder johnny
ich will den zug okay hier hilfe klasse blockiert mal nicht den ganzen stand
kommen wir schauen mal was da drüben gibt ich bin kein hilfeklose
weißt du was ab jetzt nenne ich dich nur noch hilfeklösschen verarsch mich nicht
das schicksal hat wundervolle fügung für euch bereit aus diesem hier könnt
ihr anwalt werden und aus diesem hier ein arzt tf kommt ihr zwei ich kaufe euch
südlichkeiten hey wo ist mein trinkgeld
hey wo ist wo ist johnny hin da furcht
wo sein hier das werden drei mal links bedeutet okay ich habe sie übersehen
wo sind sie denn
bin ich blind hierunter was da furcht
was was über sehe ich denn jetzt gerade klopft den was klopft den maulwurf ist
das nicht hier quälerein da sind ja keine echten maulwürfe genau so haben
die leute dampf abgelassen bevor ego shooter erfunden wurden wie primitiv
ganz schön getto alter wo hast du davon gelesen mein opa war ein fan davon
wollen sie ein spielchen wagen einfach alle köpfe klopfen und alle preise
gewinnen ja ja ja und ein mit der nein nein ich will nicht hammer spielen
hallo oh nee was zu teufel mit der stu mit dem steuer ach du scheiß was das
für eine dämliche steuerung ich will es muss das mit der maus machen doch nicht
mit der tastatur ist es denn ist es denn total hängen geblieben das ding
mit der tastatur ich kann das nicht mit der maus steuern das ist ja fail kann ich
ja gar nicht mein krassen mein krasses flick aim verwenden das ja anstrengend
und die steuerung ist übelst und genau ok zeit ist um die sie reicht
das ergibt 61 prozent das ist ein neuer rekord wat ok
ok dafür gab es memo gelegt ich musste das also machen ok gut gut zu wissen
nein was muss ich denn machen die steuerung hast du gewählt ja ok stimmt
ich habe einfach escape gedrückt habe ich jetzt eigentlich drei memory links
ich habe ich habe zwei memory links ok ein memory link fehlt noch ich
zahme bin ich irgendwie blind oder was
man wo muss ich denn jetzt was machen
dem tue habe ich doch schon geredet
ach hier unten willkommen ich präsentiere die kleines das kleinste
riesen rad der welt ja ist sehr groß können wir eine probefahrt machen
natürlich nicht funktioniert es überhaupt natürlich nicht einfach
ein paar stühle drangeklebt ja es sieht nicht wirklich aus wie ein riesen rad
ok weiter geht es wir haben drei memory links
bei gehen wir jetzt da lang oder gehen wir da lang ich könnte wetten es macht
eigentlich gar keinen unterschied
gehen jetzt hier lang weil die richtung sind sie auch gelaufen ja
gibt's hier kleiner joey kleiner johnny hapa hapa ich werde dich nie verstehen
joey wie kannst du nur diesen geschmack ertragen sie sind so sauer sie füttern
gurken
johnny ist später immer mehr zu joey geworden und gar nicht mehr selbst hat
sogar gurken gefuttert obwohl er guck dich mochte beziehungsweise er konnte
sich ja nicht mehr erinnern und seine mutter hat ihn quasi einfach so erzogen
zu johnny äh zu joey sauer und super das sind sie probier doch mal
könnt ihr wenigstens eine probieren johnny wer weiß vielleicht kommst du
damit auch auf den geschmack genau
ich bin fertig mama kann ich spielen gehen ok aber nur auf dem spielplatz
nicht ein meter weiter gib mir die tasche ich pass für dich darauf auf
nein das ist meins habe ich gewonnen
eingelegte oliven
geben wir johnny hinterher fünf mulllings ok ich muss noch
irgendwas anklicken
warte muss ich anklicken
was gibt es denn hier noch was muss ich hier noch machen
das glitzert so da muss ich doch bestimmt hin oder was ist hier
ich hab's easy einfach einfach lang laufen ok gehen wir mal so hinterher
johnny fang ich bring ich auch schon immer durch
versteht er ja
wo geht er hin er darf doch nur auf den spielplatz aber
natürlich hört er wieder auf seine mutter nicht aber macht das in dem alter
schon auf einmal hören wir nicht so gut was
sein halt eine teile
Will er dann hin?
Wow
Ja, da hat er Sebaro recht
Wir werden gleich erfahren warum Johnny zum Mond will
Okay, er hat den Weg, okay, er hat den Weg verlassen und einen coolen Ort gefunden
Aber seien wir ehrlich, er hätte ebenso gut von einem Rudel-Tiger angefallen werden können
Tiger leben nicht in Rudel, nur Durfkopf
Das war auch nur eine Redensart
Weißt du, als ich noch klein war hat mich mein Opa jedes Jahr zum Sternengucken mitgenommen
Ja
Es gab ein Hügel außerhalb der Stadt, wo wir immer standen. Derselbe Hügel, jedes Jahr
Wir schauen
Was, Little Samso, mir fällt gerade erst mal auf, dass du den Hintergrund hier aus dem Spiel hast
Ne, hab ich nicht, ich hab nur den Hintergrund mit Mond und Stern gesucht
Wir schauen in die Sterne, bis dann morgen, der Mathe. Und ja, ich schaute hauptsächlich, er hat nur das Teleskop für mich getragen
Natürlich
Nun hätte Mama mir allerdings niemals erlaubt die ganze Nacht wach zu bleiben
Deshalb sagte Opa ihr jedes Mal, dass wir nur Zelten fahren und versteckt ihr das Teleskop im Auto
Das war toll, aber wenn wir die ganze Nacht wach bleiben, dann haben wir nur das Teleskop im Auto
Das war toll, aber wenn wir am Morgen zurück kamen, wusste ich sie nur, als hätte ich nachts geschlafen
Und das ist kurz gefasst die Geschichte, wie ich in die Koffeinsucht abdriftete
Du bist ein Monstrum, ich weiß
Es ist schon sehr traurig
All diese schönen Erinnerungen verloren und niemals wiedergefunden
Und wer weiß, wie viele mehr es noch gibt
Tja, wie du immer sagst, man muss jeden Moment für sich genießen, nicht?
Yo
Ho? WTF?
Ich hab dir doch gesagt, hier gibt es Tigerrudel
Das ist die kleine River
Daran sieht man, Johnny und River kannten sich schon lange vor der Schule
Johnny weiß es bloß nicht mehr
Allerdings River weiß es noch
Warte, bleib hier
Ich bin Johnny, und wie heißt du?
Du bist an meinem Platz
Was, dein Platz?
Äh, tut mir leid, ich wollte mich hier nicht ganz alleine ausbreiten
Willst du dich zu mir setzen?
Bist du hier um die Sterne zu beobachten?
Äh, und du?
Schau nur
Wusstest du, dass es so viele Lichter am Himmel gibt?
Yo
Äh, ja wusste ich, ich wusste das auch
Das ist also dein Platz, ja?
Nur während des Jahrmarkts
Kein Fan von Menschenmengen?
Bin ich auch nicht
Weißt du, du hast mir immer noch nicht deinen Namen gesagt
Ich sag ihn dir auch nicht
In der Schule machen sich alle darüber lustig
Warum?
Sie sagen, dass
Sie sagen, dass sie aufs Klo müssen, wenn sie an ihn denken
Äh, aha
Ja, dann sag ihn mir halt nicht
Tja, es kann doch eigentlich nichts schlimmer als John sein
Ich meine
Überall auf der Welt heißt fast jeder John
Auch in Indien
Das wird mich nicht wundern
Was ist denn verkehrt daran?
Hä?
Was ist verkehrt daran, einen Namen zu haben, den jeder hat?
Es ist langweilig, denke ich
Ich meine, wenn alle so heißen, wo ist denn der Sinn?
Ich hätte nichts dagegen
Ausnahmsweise mal den gleichen Namen zu haben, den alle anderen auch haben
Das ist wie mit diesen Lichtern am Himmel
Von hier unten sehen sie alle gleich aus
Aber das macht den einzelnen Sternen kein bisschen weniger schön
Ja, vielleicht
Diese ganzen Sterne da oben, was glaubst du, sind sie?
Mein Vater sagt, sie sind riesige Brändekugeln aus Gas
Da hat er recht
Ach, das denkt er sich doch nur aus
Warum sollte er mich dann anlügen?
Weil, äh, das machen Erwachsene halt, die denken sich komische Sachen aus
Den Weihnachtsmann, der Osterhase, Kängurus, so Zeug halt
Hast du schon mal versucht, den Osterhasen aus Sternen zu machen?
Du meinst wie ein Sternbild?
Ja
Ähm, andere Sachen schon, aber noch nie einen Hase
Möchtest du einen machen?
Klar, machen wir das beste Sternbild aller Zeiten
Mal sehen, wer zuerst eins hat
Okay
Von drei
Drei, zwei, eins und los
Ich seh's
Tja, River ist schnell mit sowas
Hä? Was wie? So schnell?
Am Himmel
Wo genau am Himmel?
Denk in großen Zusammenhängen, Johnny
Ähm, größer als alle die anderen es tun
Hä? Ich versteh's nicht
Moment mal, warte mal
Ich seh's
Sag mir, was du siehst
Da drüben, stimmt's? Da sind die zwei Löffel und der Kopf
Und weiter?
Da sind seine Füße
Äh, und was noch?
Ihr merkt schon, sie fragt ihn genau das gleiche wie bei den Papierhasen, ne?
Und der Mond?
Und der Mond ist sein großer Unterbauch
Wir wissen auch immer noch nicht, warum Johnny auf den Mond will
Aber ich glaub, du in zwei, drei Dialogboxen erfahren wirst
Also, was glaubst du, sind sie wirklich?
Die Sterne meine ich
Ich...
Ich habe es noch nie jemandem erzählt, aber ich habe immer gedacht, dass sie Leuchttürme sind
Milliarden von Leuchttürmen, die fest sitzen am anderen Ende des Himmels
Wow, muss ganz schön was los sein da oben
Ist aber nicht so
Sie können all die anderen Leuchttürme dort draußen sehen und sie wollen mit ihnen reden
Aber das können sie nicht, denn sie sind alle viel zu weit voneinander entfernt, um zu hören, was die anderen sagen
Sie können nichts tun, außer aus der Ferne ihr Licht schicken
Also tun sie das
Sie senden ihr Licht zu den anderen Leuchttürmen und zu mir
Warum zu dir?
Weil ich eines Tages mit einem von ihnen Freundschaft schließen werde
Das wissen wir ja, mit Anja später
Deine Tasche, was ist da drin?
Der Preis, den ich bei Klopp den Maulwurf gewonnen habe
Hast du schon mal gespielt?
Ich habe es versucht, aber ich bin zu ungeschickt dafür
Was hast du gekriegt?
Es ist ein Ding
Ich kann nicht wirklich sagen, was es ist
So eine Art Entenbiberding
Darf ich mal sehen?
Es sieht zu seltsam aus
Ich wünschte, ich könnte auch eins gewinnen
Johnny, wo steckst du denn?
Mama ruft mich, ich muss weg
Hier nimm es wieder
Weißt du was, behalt es, es gehört dir
Mir?
Ja, ich kann jederzeit noch eins gewinnen
Ich will er nicht angeben, aber ich bin einfach der Beste bei diesem Spiel
Bis nächstes Jahr wieder hier?
Ja, du auch?
Klar
Selber Ort, selbe Zeit
Ja
Und wenn du es vergisst oder wir uns aus den Augen verlieren?
Ich habe jetzt mal nichts gesagt
Das ist der Grund, warum Johnny auf den Mond will
Und er kann sich nicht dran erinnern, weil er komische Medikamente nehmen musste
Und seine Mutter ihn versucht hat zu Joey umzuerziehen
Und deswegen wollte er in der Schule auch mit River zusammen sein
Weil er die ganze Zeit jemand anderes sein sollte
Aber eigentlich wollte er nur er sein
Dann treffen wir uns auf dem Mond wieder Dummlchen
Auf dem Bauch des Hasen
Erinnert euch noch dran, dass River Johnny einen dicken Hasen gebastelt hat aus dem Papier?
Das ergibt jetzt alles Sinn, oder?
Sie wollte ihm noch die ganze Zeit erzählen, dass er sich dran erinnert
Aber er hat es halt nicht mal gecheckt
Johnny
Ich bin schon unterwegs
Mein Hackysack ist noch in der Tasche
Du sagst es, du bist ungestickt, stimmt's? Versuch's damit
Falls sie sich jemals aus den Augen verlieren
Moment mal, soll das heißen?
Sag mir nicht, du hast das nicht kommen sehen
Und ich hatte schon geglaubt, dass hier würde eine inspirierende Kindheitstrauma-Geschichte werden
Ich hätte wissen sollen, dass irgendein Mädchen auftaucht und einen Schmachtfetzen daraus macht
Ich glaube, wir wissen jetzt, was wir tun müssen, um ihn zum Mond zu bringen
Moment mal, du willst doch nicht etwa das wirklich tun, oder?
Es ist unser Job, Neil
Nein
So lautet unser Auftrag
Verdammt noch mal, Eva, nein, das kannst du nicht machen
Eva
Ich weiß, dass du hier irgendwo bist
Wo hat sich Eva versteckt?
Da ist sie
Umdrehen
Neil, ich weiß, was du vorhast
Ich weiß, dass du das weißt
Ja, und nun, ich weiß, dass du weißt, dass ich weiß
Hör mal, unser Job ist, ihn zum Mond zu bringen
Und das wird nur dann passieren, wenn Johnny motiviert ist, dieses Ziel zu verfolgen
Aber wenn wir dafür River entfernen müssten, was soll die Sache dann überhaupt noch bringen?
Er will überhaupt nur deshalb zum Mond, weil sie gestorben ist
Das ist ihm quasi in dem Moment, wo seine Frau gestorben ist, wieder eingefallen
Unterbewusst, er wusste das ja nicht mehr
Wir sind gesetzlich dazu verpflichtet, diesen Vertrag zu erfüllen
Scheiß auf den Vertrag
Ich habe diesen Job nicht angenommen, um ihm die Lebensfreude zu nehmen, Eva
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie du das siehst, aber ich mache das hier, damit der alte Knacker mit einem Lächeln im Gesicht sterben kann
Ich doch auch, und ich mag meinen Job
Aber wenn wir gegen unsere gesetzlichen Pflichten verstoßen, sehen wir uns vor Gericht wieder
Das werden wir anfechten, wir wissen, dass Johnny glücklicher wird, wenn er nicht zum Mond fliegt
Es gibt viele alternative Lebenstangenten, denen Johnny glücklicher wäre, Naya
Wir sind nicht hier um Gott zu spielen, es ist unser Job ihm zu geben, was er bestellt hat
Zufällig wissen wir aber, was er will, besser als er selbst
Verstehe doch, ich riskiere River doch nur deswegen, weil ich an sie glaube
Und was soll das heißen, du riskierst sie, du entfernst sie
Außerdem werde ich es wiedergut machen
Wiedergut machen, wie denn?
Uns läuft die Zeit davon, Naya
Vertrau mir einfach
Sagt die Frau, die mich von dem scheiß Leuchtturm geschubst hat
Verdammte Lichtwerte, mit deinen Krumpturnen schaltest du meinen Zugriff nicht vollständig ab, Eva
Versteckte Fallen, wirklich? Ich versuche nur Zeit zu gewinnen
Danke, dass du Bescheid sagst, bewegen
Im Prinzip kann dir in dem Game nichts passieren
Das ist ziemlich teure Ausrüstung, die du hier durch die Gegend wirfst
Ich meine das ernst, bleib einfach wo du bist und warte bis ich fertig bin
Ach du kannst mich mal, ähm, sonst wo
Hier ist nichts
Hör mal, zwing mich nicht dazu hier auszusteigen und dir den Stecker zu ziehen
Du würdest ernsthaft riskieren, dass deine Erinnerungen in diesem kaputten Zustand bleiben
Hör einfach auf, bitte, ich brauch nicht lang
Oh nee, schon wieder
Oder komm doch und hol mich, ich bin am Ende des Flurs
Das weißt du doch nicht ernst, findest du das witzig, Eva?
Das sind nicht einfach nur Zombie-Evas, das sind Zombiefars
Kein Schritt näher, ich bin bewaffnet
Was, WASD benutzen?
Alter die Steuerung, die Steuerung, die Steuerung ist so fail
Also sind die Dinger doch sowas gut
Wie darf, halte
Das ist alles nur eine Schleife
Muss ich vielleicht hier runter, oh Scheiß drauf
WTF
Eva, was ist passiert, äh, Eva?
Das ergibt der Wildes keinen Sinn mehr hier drin jetzt
Ich hab immer gedacht, dass die Leuchttürme sind, das ganze System versinkt im Chaos
Milliarden von Leuchttürmen, die fest sitzen am anderen Ende des Himmels
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr jetzt
Es wird ihnen helfen, den Zustand ihrer Partnerin zu verstehen, lieber nicht, warum das
Das kennen wir ja alles
Das ist nicht so gewesen ist, wie es jetzt aussieht
Zumindest Johnny geht es auch nicht sonderlich gut gerade
Hallo, bleib hier, ich bin Johnny und wie heißt du?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr
Das ist jetzt wie bei Matrix ein Telefon
Was hier ist Eva, du Trottel
Kein Scheiß, wir sind die einzigen hier
Was auch immer du gerade tust, hör auf damit, wir wissen vielleicht nicht was Johnny will, aber wir wissen genau was er nicht will
Und genau das beschwörst du gerade herauf, es ist bereits geschehen all
Warum kommst du da nicht endlich raus
Da ist sie ja
Was hast du mit ihr gemacht, entspann dich sie geht nur woanders hin
Weißt du, es ist eine Sache meinen Zugriff zu blockieren, um mich mit ein paar Oliven zu füttern
Aber das hier ist jenseits von Gut und Böse, tut mir leid, aber das hier führt zu gar nichts, wenn du weiter die Erinnerungen zurücksetzt
Aber jetzt ist der einzige Weg, du musst mir vertrauen
Wo willst du denn noch hin
Es gibt noch eine allerletzte Sache die ich erledigen muss
Warum kämpfst du so hart darum, dass ich, fuck jetzt habe ich es übersprungen, für das hier, vergess es wir haben keine Zeit
Das wird schon Mann, dreh dich einfach um
Ja Johnny will sie ansprechen und Riffa ist weg
Aber das Treffen zwischen Johnny auf dem Jahrmarkt, zwischen Johnny und Riffa auf dem Jahrmarkt, das wurde nicht gelöscht
Das erste wo sie anscheinend anfangen das ganze zu löschen ist, als Johnny Riffa in der Schule wieder getroffen hat und sich nicht mehr daran erinnern konnte, dass er sie schon kennt
Sie ist weg
Sorry Kleiner, jetzt gibt es kein Zurück mehr
Das Game geht noch ungefähr 10-15 Minuten
Los jetzt, sonst sind alle guten Tische besetzt, die sind alle gleich gut Mensch
Johnny hat Recht, an denen in der Nähe der Küche riecht es besser, guck mal sein Bruder lebt wieder, zumindest so wie er sich das ganze einbildet
Ganz genau und man muss sich nur umdrehen um einen Oliven Nachschlag zu kriegen
Er kann sich immer eine neue Riffa suchen, aber sein Bruder gibt es nur einmal
Jetzt komm wir stehen im Weg
Und weg ist Riffa
Die das singt ist die Sonnenblume aus Plants vs Zombies
Johnny will Astronaut werden
Warum will Johnny Astronaut werden, weil er jetzt früher schon gemerkt hat, dass er Riffa sehen will, ohne dass es ihm so richtig klar ist
Warum will Johnny Astronaut werden, weil es ihm so richtig klar ist
Johnny Astronaut werden, weil es ihm so richtig klar ist
To the Moon
The Moon